I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Angela. Hello, everybody.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎，女士们。你好，安吉拉。大家好。
Hello and hello. Today we're going to talk about costume contest. Oh, there's lots to discuss. It's season seven, episode six, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Dean Holland. I loved seeing us in our costumes the whole time. I have lots to share about that penguin. I loved the penguin so much, particularly in your talking head. Oh.
大家好。今天我们要聊的是服装大赛。哦，有太多内容要讨论了。这是第七季第六集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，迪恩·霍兰德执导。我很高兴看到我们全程都穿着戏服。关于那只企鹅，我有很多话要分享。我太喜欢那只企鹅了，尤其是你在面对镜头独白的时候。哦。
The penguin talking head. I have a story. But I'll wait. Okay. Here is your summary, everybody. It is Halloween at Dunder Mifflin and there is going to be a costume parade. The competition is stiff because the coworkers are vying for a valuable Halloween costume contest prize.
面对镜头独白的企鹅。我有个故事。但我先不说。好吧。各位，这是本集的剧情概要。邓德米夫林迎来了万圣节，将有一场服装游行。竞争异常激烈，因为同事们都在争夺一份珍贵的万圣节服装大赛奖品。
And everyone's real excited about it. I mean, there is a buzz about this coupon book. Meanwhile, Michael comes to resent Daryl for going over his head with a good idea. And Pam and Jim wonder why did Danny ghost Pam four years ago? They're going to get to the bottom of it. I have lots of thoughts on that storyline. I cannot wait. I'm going to hold on to them till we get there.
每个人都对此兴奋不已。我是说，这本优惠券手册引起了轰动。与此同时，迈克尔开始怨恨达里尔越过他直接提出了好主意。而帕姆和吉姆则想知道，为什么丹尼四年前会突然对帕姆不理不睬？他们要弄个水落石出。我对这条故事线有很多想法。我迫不及待了。我要留到我们聊到那里时再说。
Well, listen, everyone, today we're going to mix things up a little bit with our fast facts. Angela, do you want to share with everyone where we got this week's fast fact inspiration? I do. Okay. This is very exciting, you guys. We record at Ear Wolf, they have a P.O. box for us that's for fan mail. Jen and I don't check it.
好了，听着，各位，今天我们要用我们的“快速趣闻”来做点新尝试。安吉拉，你想跟大家分享一下我们本周“快速趣闻”的灵感来源吗？我想。好的。伙计们，这太令人兴奋了。我们在 Earwolf 录制节目，他们为我们设了一个专门收取粉丝来信的邮政信箱。詹娜和我平时不去看。
Ear Wolf checks it, but because of the pandemic, everyone hasn't been back in the office and mail has been piling up for a long time. And finally, the offices are back open, people are back in, and guess what? They checked our P.O. box. Yeah, there was so much mail, it like took up a whole little room. It was kind of crazy. And you guys know, I go through the physical mail, the snail mail, because I love tangible things, Jenna.
Earwolf 会去查看，但由于疫情，大家一直没回办公室，邮件堆积了很长时间。终于，办公室重新开放了，大家也回来了，你猜怎么着？他们查看了我们的邮政信箱。对，信件多得就像占满了一个小房间。简直太疯狂了。大家也知道，我会亲自去翻看实体邮件，也就是平信，因为我喜欢有形的东西，珍娜。
I like to touch things in my hands. This is true. You like email, you're much better at it than I am, and you do all the email mail because it's divided into grids and folders, and it all comes on my computer on a spreadsheet. And mine was just piled up in a room. They put all of our mail in a supply room, and you could barely see Angela behind this mail, but the stacks of mail were so high, and I looked at her and I just said, I'm going to stay.
我喜欢亲手触摸实物。这倒不假。你喜欢电子邮件，你比我擅长得多，而且你包揽了所有的电子邮件，因为它们被分门别类地整理在网格和文件夹里，全都发到了我电脑的电子表格上。而我的邮件就堆在一个房间里。他们把我们所有的邮件都堆在了一个杂物间里，你几乎都看不到安吉拉藏在这堆邮件后面，邮件堆得那么高，我看着她，然后我就说，我要留下来。
Yeah. I'm going to stay, we're going to go through this together. This is like a seven-person job, but we'll do it, the two of us. That's right. I was going to stay after and go through it, then, Jenna, you were like, let's order food. We're going to make a day of this. It actually turned into two days. Yeah.
对。我要留下来，我们一起把这些看完。这本来是个七个人才能干完的活儿，但我们能搞定，就我们俩。没错。我本来打算待会儿留下来看完的，然后，珍娜，你就说，我们点外卖吧。我们要把这事当成一整天的活动。结果真的变成两天了。对。
We're not even done. There's still one been left. But you guys, we were so moved by all the amazing letters and things that you sent us. These fast facts are going to be fan mail shout-outs. Woo-hoo! Boo-boo! Boo-boo! Boo-boo!
我们甚至还没看完。还剩下一部分没动。但是伙计们，你们寄给我们的所有精彩信件和物品让我们深深感动。这些“快速趣闻”将会是粉丝来信的鸣谢环节！呜呼！布布！布布！布布！
I did your bit. You did my bit. Hey, don't take my... Boo-boo! Boo-boo! That's a classic. So, where should we start? Well, I think we start with how many letters we received.
我抢了你的台词。你抢了我的台词。嘿，别拿我的……布布！布布！这真是个经典。那么，我们该从哪里开始呢？嗯，我觉得我们应该从我们收到的信件数量开始。
So many lovely letters, cards, graduation announcements, wedding invitations. I think I opened easily. I don't know, Jenna, maybe 200 wedding invitations? Maybe 300. There's so many. I haven't even gotten to all of them. I sat next to Angela while she was opening the wedding invitations and I want you to know she was genuinely delighted by each and every one.
收到了好多可爱的信件、卡片、毕业公告、婚礼请柬。我大概拆了，我不知道，珍娜，也许有 200 份婚礼请柬？也许 300 份。实在太多了。我都还没看完呢。安吉拉拆婚礼请柬的时候我就坐在她旁边，我想让你们知道，她对每一份请柬都由衷地感到高兴。
She pointed out details. I know. She took every little card out of every little folder thing. I was very impressed because you guys are real fancy. Some of them, when you open them, had like a little built-in folder for all the important pieces of paper you're going to need. Oh, and then there's this new thing. So, put the little scan square thing.
她会指出细节。我懂的。她把每一张小卡片都从每一个小文件夹里拿出来。我印象非常深刻，因为你们太讲究了。有些请柬打开时，里面甚至还有一个专门的小夹层，用来放你需要的所有重要纸质文件。哦，还有这个新玩意儿。就是放那个扫描小方块的东西。
You scan it with your phone and then it tells you all the wedding information. That made me feel old. It made me feel old, too. It's not a website. It's like a scannable thing. Like when you go to a restaurant and it's on the menu, but it's on your wedding invitation now. Also, people are really creative.
你用手机扫描它，然后它就会告诉你所有的婚礼信息。这让我觉得自己老了。这也让我觉得自己老了。这不是一个网址。而是一个像扫描件一样的东西。就像你去餐馆时看到的那种菜单，现在居然用在你的婚礼请柬上了。还有，大家真的很有创意。
One had like charred edges. Like it looked like someone had lit a flame to it, but it was intentional. Very cool. The other thing that you kept showing me, Angela, were all the people who did the little wax stamp. Yes. You loved a wax stamp. I did.
有一份请柬的边缘是焦黑的。就像有人点火烧过一样，但这绝对是刻意设计的。太酷了。安吉拉，你一直向我展示的另一件事，是所有那些使用火漆印章的人。对。你超爱火漆印章。我确实很喜欢。
Any invitation with a wax stamp, Angela showed it to me. I did. So, if you sent us a wedding invitation with a wax stamp, we both saw it. Yes. I don't know why, guys. I just want to live in yield in times. No. I get very excited about that.
只要是有火漆印章的请柬，安吉拉都会拿给我看。没错。所以，如果你寄给我们的婚礼请柬带有火漆印章，我们俩都看到了。对。我不知道为什么，伙计们。我就是想生活在古代。才不呢。我对这个非常兴奋。
I, myself, did not do a wax stamp for my wedding and I have regrets about it. But the other thing I want to share with you guys is a lot of you had office-themed weddings. And I wanted to share one of them. Oh, okay. Mary Meyer and her fiance, Justin, from St. Mary's, Pennsylvania, they met in second grade. They remained friends for years. When they were older, they started hanging out more.
我自己结婚时没有用火漆印章，对此我还有点遗憾。不过我想跟你们分享的另一件事是，你们当中有很多人举办了《办公室》主题的婚礼。我想分享其中一个。哦，好吧。玛丽·迈耶（Mary Meyer）和她的未婚夫贾斯汀来自宾夕法尼亚州圣玛丽斯，他们从二年级就认识了。他们做了多年的朋友。年纪大一些后，他们开始更频繁地一起出去玩。
And a lot of their dates included watching The Office. Jenna, you should know they named their dog Beasley. Aww. After everyone's favorite receptionist, they said, they got engaged at Niagara Falls and Mary had a, it is your bridal shower, themed bridal shower. The invitation was so cute. I think Jim and Dwight would have been very proud, Mary. If I blur all the personal information, can I put it in office lady stories?
他们的很多约会都包括观看《办公室》。珍娜，你得知道他们给自己的狗取名叫比斯利。噢。以大家最喜欢的接待员命名，他们说，他们在尼亚加拉大瀑布订婚了，玛丽举办了一个“这是你的新娘送礼会”主题的新娘送礼会。请柬太可爱了。玛丽，我想吉姆和德怀特一定会非常骄傲的。如果我把所有的个人隐私信息都模糊掉，我可以把它发在“办公室女郎故事”里吗？
Because it's so cute. Yeah. Yeah. If you take out all the stuff. Yeah. Right. Mary and Justin, we wish you all the best. Mary, thanks for sharing your bridal shower invitation with us.
因为实在是太可爱了。可以，可以。如果你把那些信息都去掉的话。可以。没错。玛丽和贾斯汀，我们祝你们一切都好。玛丽，谢谢你跟我们分享你的新娘送礼会请柬。
And you know, Jenna, as much as I love the fancy invites, I also got a real chuckle from a very simple one that we got from Caitlyn and Jeremy in Azel, Texas. Caitlyn and Jeremy sent us an invitation that just said in big all caps, free drinks and in parentheses, and we're getting married, but the first thing you saw was free drinks. And one other thing I want to share is a lot of you wrote in and told us that The Office was how you met your significant other. These stories were so sweet and fun, I wanted to share one of them. Okay.
而且你知道吗，珍娜，尽管我很喜欢那些精致的请柬，但德克萨斯州阿泽尔的凯特琳（Caitlyn）和杰里米（Jeremy）寄来的一份非常简单的请柬也让我忍俊不禁。凯特琳和杰里米寄给我们的请柬上面用醒目的大写字母写着：免费饮料，括号里写着：我们要结婚了，但你第一眼看到的就是免费饮料。我还想分享的另一件事是，你们有很多人写信告诉我们，你们是通过《办公室》结识了另一半。这些故事太甜蜜太有趣了，我想分享其中一个。好吧。
Maddie, I wrote us a letter and said to Angela, thank you. Back in 2019, you visited my school, Northern Michigan University. I had been talking to someone for a few months on a dating app, but we had yet to meet. We were both on the shy side. Your Q and A popped up and we both love the office. So we decided that this would be our first date. I know. Maddie goes on to say, let me tell you, it was perfect.
麦迪（Maddie）给我们写了一封信，对安吉拉说：“谢谢你。”早在 2019 年，你访问了我的学校——北密歇根大学。我当时在一个约会软件上跟一个人聊了几个月，但我们还没见过面。我们俩都比较害羞。你的问答活动开始了，而我们俩都非常喜欢《办公室》。所以我们决定把这作为我们的第一次约会。我懂的。麦迪接着说，让我告诉你，简直太完美了。
There was no pressure because you did all the talking and we got to laugh at your stories about The Office, but also how you accidentally forgot to pack your underwear for the trip. Wait, what? This is a true story, Jenna. I showed up at Northern Michigan University with no underwear. Except for what you had on. Well, yeah. Okay, well.
因为全都是你在说话，所以没有任何压力，我们听着你讲关于《办公室》的故事，还有你如何不小心忘带了此行的内衣，这让我们哈哈大笑。等等，什么？珍娜，这是一个真实的故事。我到北密歇根大学时居然没带内衣。除了你身上穿的那条。好吧，对。好吧，嗯。
But just saying. I was going to be there three days. Oh, wow. Yeah. I hope you found some, by the way, after that day, we were inseparable and now her and I are engaged. Yay. I know.
但我是说。我本来要在那儿待三天呢。哦，哇。对啊。顺便说一句，希望你后来找到了，从那天起，我们形影不离，现在我和她订婚啦。耶。我知道。
Office made up. Congratulations. Office made cute. That's an Angela meat cute. Oh, yeah. I think you created that meat cute. I love it. Yay.
因《办公室》结缘。恭喜。因《办公室》结缘，太甜蜜了。这就是安吉拉式的浪漫邂逅。哦，对。我想这个浪漫邂逅是你促成的。我太喜欢了。耶。
Well, I want to talk about all the homemade items that we received, like overwhelmed with just the generosity and the hand craftsmanship, just the most thoughtful, most beautiful things. You guys sent us homemade napkins, hand stitched, we had candles and bath soaps. Pot holders. Office themed pot holders that you all made, t-shirts. We got homemade jewelry, knit hats. I got a giant cat floaty for my swimming pool. My kids are very excited about that.
嗯，我想聊聊我们收到的所有手工制品，简直被大家的慷慨和精湛的手艺惊艳到了，全都是最贴心、最美丽的物品。你们给我们寄了手工餐巾纸、手工刺绣品、蜡烛和沐浴皂。隔热垫。你们亲手制作的《办公室》主题隔热垫、T恤。我们收到了手工首饰、针织帽。我还为我的游泳池收到了一个巨大的猫咪浮排。我的孩子们对此兴奋不已。
Lots of really beautiful wood crafts, cookies, buttons, pins, stickers. A lot of you really wanted Jenna to have a mug with her face on it, like the one from Kelly's party. Yes. You got a few of those. Then a lot of you also wanted me to have a coffee mug that said, it's basically bread that looks like a donut. Yeah.
还有很多非常漂亮的木雕、饼干、纽扣、别针、贴纸。你们当中有很多人真的很想让珍娜拥有一个印有她脸庞的马克杯，就像凯莉派对上的那个一样。对。你收到了好几个那样的杯子。然后你们中也有很多人希望我能有一个咖啡杯，上面写着：“这基本上就是长得像甜甜圈的面包。”对。
We both have a lot of those coffee mugs. Yeah. Well, we both agreed that we needed to talk about one homemade item in particular. We each got a spectacular quilt from Nancy Schmidt in Minneapolis. She sent these to us back in September of 2021. We just received them, Nancy. They are amazing. Nancy, they are so beautiful.
我们俩都有很多那种咖啡杯。嗯，我们都同意，我们必须重点聊聊其中一件特定的手工制品。我们俩都收到了来自明尼阿波利斯的南希·施密特（Nancy Schmidt）制作的精美被子。她在 2021 年 9 月把这些寄给我们。南希，我们刚刚收到它们。它们太棒了。南希，它们太美了。
For those of you guys that follow me on Instagram, you know that my mom, Birdie, is an amazing quilter. My grandmother, Lena, was a quilter as well. Nancy, I have watched both of them spend hours quilting a quilt for someone as a gift. I know how much time and heart goes into that. It was so moving to me. I love it so much. Well, Nancy sent us a letter where she explained in detail why she chose each fabric that she
对于那些在 Instagram 上关注我的人来说，你们知道我的妈妈伯蒂是一位出色的拼布匠。我的外祖母莉娜也是一位拼布匠。南希，我看着她俩花了好几个小时为某人缝制一床被子作为礼物。我知道这其中倾注了多少时间和心血。这太让我感动了。我太喜欢了。南希给我们寄来了一信件，在信中她详细解释了她选择每一款布料的原因。
chose. I mean, so much thought and care goes into these quilts. She said that one of the fabrics that she added reminded her of the palm trees that we said sometimes sneak into the background of the office. I loved that. And then Nancy also said this in her letter to us, I'll never forget the safety training episode where the two of you dove in and talked about suicide. You saw the necessity of saying something about it and what you did was both loving and brave.
我是说，这些被子倾注了太多的心思和关爱。她说她添加其中一款布料时，想起了我们曾说过有时会悄悄出现在《办公室》背景中的棕榈树。我太喜欢这个细节了。然后南希在给我们的信中还写了这样一段话：“我永远不会忘记那个安全培训的集，你们两个人在其中深入探讨了自杀。你们看到了表态的必要性，你们所做的事既充满爱意又非常勇敢。”
Well, Nancy, thank you for that. And thank you so much for the quilts. Yes, Nancy. I will be using mine all the time. One of the other things I want to talk about, Jenna, is the amazing artists that listen to Office Ladies Pod. We got several paintings of Jenna and myself, either as our characters or of ourselves in real life.
南希，谢谢你的这番话。也非常感谢你送的被子。是的，南希。我会一直使用我的那条。珍娜，我想聊的另一件事，是收听“办公室女郎”播客的才华横溢的艺术家们。我们收到了几幅关于珍娜和我的画作，画的要么是我们的角色，要么是我们现实生活中的样子。
And I wanted to shout out Ellen, who is 13 years old. She painted a big picture of Jenna and I plus little ones of our characters. She shared in a letter to us that she loves art and Jane Austen novels and mugs. And Ellen, I want you to know, I love all of those things. In fact, I have a coffee mug with all of the quotes from Pride and Prejudice. Don't even get me started on Mr. Darcy. Well, a lot of you also shared with us how the podcast got you through long commutes or hardships in your life, the pandemic, or how it just kind of kept you company in
我想在这里向 13 岁的埃伦（Ellen）致意。她画了一张我和珍娜的大幅画像，还有我们角色的Q版小画像。她在信中跟我们分享说，她热爱艺术、简·奥斯汀的小说和马克杯。埃伦，我想让你知道，这些我都爱。事实上，我有一个印满《傲慢与偏见》名言的咖啡杯。千万别让我开始聊达西先生，不然我停不下来。嗯，还有很多人跟我们分享了这档播客是如何陪他们度过漫长的通勤时光、生活中的艰难时期、疫情，或者它如何以这样或那样的形式一直陪伴着他们。我想重点朗读的一封信来自达斯汀·M（Dustin M.）。达斯汀说，我是一所学校的第二班次清洁工。每天晚上大约有四个小时，我独自一人在楼里打扫卫生。你们两个人在我工作时陪伴着我，让我开怀大笑。
one form or another. And one of the letters I wanted to highlight was from Dustin M. Dustin said, I am a second shift custodian for a school. And for about four hours a night, I am alone in the building cleaning. You two keep me company and laughing while at work. He went on to say, I wanted to share a little of my story and my family's story. And he sent us a photo of him and his wife and their two kids. They're gorgeous.
他接着说，我想分享一点我和我家人的故事。他还给我们寄了一张他和妻子以及两个孩子的照片。他们太好看了。
It was their Christmas card from last year. Here's what Dustin said. When you had Ellie Kemper on the show a few weeks ago, it reminded me of how much I loved her storyline with the foster care system and trying to find her parents. My wife and I were foster parents ourselves for a few years and have been lucky enough to adopt both of our beautiful children from the system. Vivi was one when we adopted her. After taking her straight from the hospital, she is now four and a bundle of joy and energy.
那是他们去年的圣诞贺卡。达斯汀是这么说的：几周前你们请埃利·坎珀（Ellie Kemper）上节目时，让我想起了我是多么喜欢她关于寄养系统以及试图寻找父母的故事线。我和妻子自己也当了几年的寄养父母，并且非常幸运地从这个系统中收养了我们两个美丽的孩子。我们收养维维（Vivi）时她才一岁。在把她直接从医院接回家后，她现在已经四岁了，是个充满快乐和精力的可爱小精灵。
What to be outdone is my son Hank, who was also one when we adopted him after getting him from another foster family when he was four months old. He is currently three and will pick on his sister any chance he gets. He went on to say that he loved the episode where Andy talks about frothing. Dustin actually has a company that sells disc golf equipment. Dustin said, we call it disc golf, but we love frothing. And Dustin even named his company V&H Disc Golf after his kids. And then he ended his letter by saying, thank you for spending time with me each week and
毫不逊色的是我的儿子汉克（Hank），我们收养他时他也是一岁，当时他在四个月大时被另一个寄养家庭收养，后来我们接手了。他现在三岁了，只要有机会就会捉弄姐姐。他接着说，他很喜欢安迪谈论起泡的那个集。达斯汀其实有一家销售飞盘高尔夫器材的公司。达斯汀说，我们管这叫飞盘高尔夫，但我们超爱起泡。达斯汀甚至以他的孩子们的名字将他的公司命名为 V&H 飞盘高尔夫。他在信的结尾写道：谢谢你们每周花时间陪伴我，并分享所有的幕后故事，圣诞快乐，新年快乐。谢谢你，达斯汀。这不是最甜蜜的信吗？
sharing all the behind the scenes stories, Merry Christmas and Happy New Year. Thank you Dustin. Isn't that the sweetest letter? Yes, I love it. Thank you so much for sharing that with us and he sent us one of his disc golf frisbees. The other thing Jen and I couldn't get over was just how many different places letters and things come from. Now I know Jenna with email, you really get people from all over, but you know, mail,
对，我太喜欢了。非常感谢你跟我们分享这些，他还给我们寄了一个他的飞盘高尔夫飞盘。我和珍娜百思不得其解的另一件事，是信件和物品寄来的地方实在是太五花八门了。我知道珍娜，通过电子邮件，你确实能收到来自世界各地的人的信息，但是邮件，
that takes effort to put something in an envelope, pay for the postage to go out of the country. Yeah. And there were lots of letters that were moving to us. I want to say thank you to Andy Jay from the UK who wrote in and said, I've been an office fan for years and now enjoy listening to office ladies whilst driving around for work. He went on to share with us that he makes wooden name plaques and he sent one to Jenna and myself. Andy, we love them.
把东西放进信封、支付寄到国外的邮资，这些都是需要付出努力的。是的。有许多信件让我们感动。我要感谢来自英国的安迪·杰伊（Andy Jay），他写信说：我一直是《办公室》的粉丝，现在我喜欢在开车工作时收听“办公室女郎”。他接着跟我们分享说，他制作木制姓名牌，并给我们俩各寄了一个。安迪，我们太喜欢了。
They're so cute. And guess what? Here's the other thing we want to share with you guys. We now have desks. We have desks at Ear Wolf. We each have a desk. We kind of pammed it. We did pamp it.
它们太可爱了。你猜怎么着？我们还有一件事要跟你们分享。我们现在有办公桌了。我们在 Earwolf 有了办公桌。我们每个人都有一个办公桌。我们把它们装点了一番。我们确实装点了一番。
Who pammed it? You did. I pammed it. You said, who's sitting at these two empty desks? Can we take them? And they said, sure. And then, you guys, all of the beautiful things you sent in, we used to decorate our office space here at Office Ladies.
谁装点得？你装点得。我装点得。你说，谁坐在那两张空办公桌旁？我们可以用吗？他们说，当然可以。然后，伙计们，你们寄来的所有精美物品，都被我们用来装饰我们在“办公室女郎”这里的办公空间了。
We'll put it in stories, but all of your pictures and paintings and things you sent, we have the cutest nook at Ear Wolf now. And it has already paid off because we can sit side by side undisturbed by the distractions of home life and chores and all that. We have like a real office space. It's so exciting. It's so exciting. You know what cracks me up, Jenna?
我们会把它发到快拍里，但是你们寄来的所有照片、画作和东西，让我们现在在 Earwolf 拥有了最可爱的角落。这已经有了回报，因为我们可以并肩坐着，不受家庭生活、家务以及诸如此类事情的干扰。我们有了一个真正的办公空间。太令人兴奋了。太令人兴奋了。你知道什么让我觉得好笑吗，珍娜？
Because we spent nine years being in fake work booths, sort of side by side through a partition. And now we're so excited to be in a real work pause desk area. I didn't even think of that. But it's great because we want to tell you we are currently using our desks to sign copies of the office BFFs for the holidays. So look out for that. Yeah.
因为我们花了九年时间坐在虚构的工作隔间里，隔着隔板勉强算并肩作战。而现在我们能在一个真正的办公桌区域并肩工作，这让我们兴奋不已。我甚至都没想到这一点。但太棒了，因为我们要告诉大家，我们目前正在使用我们的办公桌为节假日签名售卖《办公室好闺蜜》的书籍。所以敬请期待哦。对。
It's going to be on OfficeLadies.com. We're going to do a really fun holiday bundle with our book. Well, finally, before we go to break, Taylor E. and Alberta Canada sent us something I'm very excited about. I'm also not excited about it. I don't know my feelings about it. Taylor, I'm super excited because one of them I have had and the other I have not. Here's what Taylor sent us.
这将在 OfficeLadies.com 上线。我们要围绕我们的书推出一个非常有趣的节日礼包。好了，最后，在我们进入广告休息之前，来自加拿大艾伯塔省的泰勒·E（Taylor E.）寄给我们一样让我非常兴奋的东西。我也对它没什么感觉。我对它心情复杂。泰勒，我超级兴奋，因为这些东西其中一样我吃过，另一样我没吃过。以下是泰勒寄给我们的东西。
Some old Dutch chips. Remember these were featured in the episode Business Trip. Old Dutch chips were founded in Winnipeg in 1954 and Old Dutch has the crazy flavors. Yes. So here's what we've got here. We've got the Dill Pickle flavor. It's Dill Pickle and onion. Oh boy.
一些老荷兰牌薯片。大家还记得这些在集数《出差》中出现过吗？老荷兰牌薯片于 1954 年在温尼伯创立，老荷兰牌有各种疯狂的口味。是的。所以我们这里有这些。我们有莳萝泡菜口味。是莳萝泡菜洋葱味的。哦，天哪。
And then ketchup flavored chips. I've had the ketchup ones. I'm really excited. And you liked them. I did like it. Okay. And then the last thing, she sent us something from Ruffles. They're called the All Dressed Chip and Taylor thinks that that is a Canada specific flavor.
然后是番茄酱口味的薯片。我吃过番茄酱味的。我真的很兴奋。而且你很喜欢。我确实挺喜欢的。好的。然后最后一样东西，她给我们寄了来自乐事的薯片。它们被称为“全味薯片”（All Dressed），泰勒认为这是一种加拿大特有的口味。
Okay. I have not had that. Let's open them up. All right. All right. Well, we're getting ready. I want to say Taylor. Oh, that's loud.
好吧。我没吃过那个。我们打开它们尝尝吧。好吧。好吧。好了，在我们准备的时候，我想说，泰勒。哦，声音好大。
That was very loud. Sorry. Okay. Let me say before we taste the chips that Taylor also said, quote, living in a fairly rural area in Alberta, I don't ever get to see or meet celebrities or be part of Hollywood. Though, it once made it into our newspaper that Helena Bonham Carter visited a coffee shop in our city. No.
声音太大了。抱歉。好吧，在品尝薯片之前，我想说泰勒还写道，引用一下：“住在艾伯塔省一个相当偏远的地区，我从没机会见到或结识名流，也没有机会成为好莱坞的一部分。虽然有一次海伦娜·伯翰·卡特（Helena Bonham Carter）参观我们城市的一家咖啡馆上了我们的报纸。”
So it's special to listen to your podcast every week and get a bit of a glimpse into the magic of Hollywood. Taylor, thank you for your letter and thank you for the chips. And I'm going to try what I guess is still pickle and onion. Okay. Sam, Cassie, do you want to try any? Yeah, you want to try these? You want some?
所以每周收听你们的播客，并一窥好莱坞的魔力，是一件很特别的事。泰勒，谢谢你的信，也谢谢你寄来的薯片。我要尝尝我猜是莳萝泡菜洋葱味的这个。好的。萨姆、凯西，你们想尝尝吗？对，你们想尝尝这个吗？你们想吃点吗？
There's a little bit of a reluctant look from Cassie. Okay. How's the Dill? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I like it. I don't like it.
凯西看起来有点不情愿。好吧。莳萝味的怎么样？对。对。好吧。我喜欢。我不喜欢。
Okay. Drink some water. I don't care for it. Okay. I'm trying Dill pickle and onion. I like it. What? I like it.
好吧。喝点水。我不喜欢这个。好吧。我来尝尝莳萝泡菜洋葱味的。我喜欢。什么？我喜欢。
Who? What is your... What is... I don't get it. Oh, look at the... Look at this. Look at that. Would you...
谁？你的……这是什么……我不懂。哦，看这个。看这个。看那个。你……
Tell them what you're eating. This is ketchup. Uh-huh. Oh, my gosh. I wish you could see Jenna's face. Can I have to take a picture of your face? Pass them over to me. Uh-huh.
告诉大家你在吃什么。这是番茄酱味的。嗯哼。哦，天哪。我真希望你们能看到珍娜的表情。我能拍一张你脸部的照片吗？把它递给我。嗯哼。
Who would eat this willingly? Oh, my God. Again. I like it. Oh, boy. Okay. I need Sam and Cassie to try these. Sam.
谁会自愿吃这个？哦，天哪。再來。我喜欢。哦，天哪。好吧。我需要萨姆和凯西来尝尝这些。萨姆。
Oh, wait. Who's... Who's in the booth with Sam and Cassie? That's Phil. Hi, Phil. That's Phil. Oh, my gosh. Hello.
哦，等等。是谁……谁在和萨姆、凯茜一起在录音室里？那是菲尔。嗨，菲尔。那是菲尔。噢，天哪。你好。
Phil. Phil. Would you... Would you like it? You're a food guy. Yes. You have a whole podcast about food. Yes, you do.
菲尔。菲尔。你愿意……你想要吗？你是个美食家。是的。你有一个专门讲美食的播客。是的，你有。
Okay. Come here. Have you ever had old Dutch chips? They are Canadian and they have these crazy flavors. Have a seat. Phil. Rosenthal. What am I eating?
好吧。过来。你吃过老荷兰薯片吗？它们是加拿大的，有这些疯狂的口味。请坐。菲尔·罗森塔尔。我在吃什么？
This is dill, pickle, and onion. This is dill, pickle, and onion. Cornishaws and ranch. It sounds very fancy. Thoughts? Not terrible. Okay. She hated it.
这是莳萝、泡菜和洋葱。这是莳萝、泡菜和洋葱。还有玉米卷饼干和牧场酱。听起来很高档。有什么感想？不糟糕。好吧。她讨厌它。
I love it. I love that one. Yep. I loved it. I did. I would eat that whole bag. But I hated this more. Okay.
我喜欢。我喜欢那个。是的。我很喜欢。确实如此。我会把整袋都吃完。但我更讨厌这个。好吧。
This is just called ketchup. Yeah. I feel like we're getting a real food connoisseur's opinion now. I know. Yeah. What do you think? What do you think? Why are you laughing?
这个就叫番茄酱。是的。我觉得我们现在听到的是一个真正的美食鉴赏家的意见。我知道。是的。你觉得呢？你觉得呢？你为什么在笑？
That's not so good. Oh, thank you. I liked it. Thank you. How many others do you have? We have one more. Oh, I've had these. All dressed.
那个没那么好。哦，谢谢你。我挺喜欢的。谢谢。你们还有多少种？我们还有一个。哦，我吃过这个。全味薯片。
Yeah. Spell... Say that in French. You're fancy. Essosienne. Oh, nice. I don't know. Essosienne.
对。拼写……用法语说出来。你很讲究。Essosienne。哦，不错。我不知道。Essosienne。
Essosienne. Essosienne. I'm just doing my French dick. Okay. Let's try it. Those are good. You would eat those. No, you don't like it?
Essosienne。Essosienne。我只是在卖弄我的法语。好吧。我们尝尝。那些很好。你会吃那些。不，你不喜欢？
You know what? I know. I took a picture of the face. I clearly should not be Canadian. Okay. Look at her face trying the ketchup one. I might make your new contact photo for my phone. Aw, that's adorable.
你知道吗？我知道。我拍下了那个表情。我显然不应该当加拿大人。好吧。看她尝番茄酱薯片时的表情。我可能会把它做成我手机里你的新联系人照片。啊，太可爱了。
You really hate it. Here's the thing. I do not like vinegar. So, I don't like the... What is that chip we do here? Salt and vinegar. Yeah, I don't care for it. No.
你是真讨厌它。事情是这样的。我讨厌醋。所以，我不喜欢……我们在这是什么薯片？盐醋味薯片。是的，我不太喜欢。不。
Okay. And so... Do you like chips and dip? Do you put... I love... Like onion dip. Yep. I love a French onion dip.
好吧。那么……你喜欢薯片配蘸酱吗？你放……我喜欢……像洋葱蘸酱。是的。我喜欢法式洋葱蘸酱。
I love a French onion chip. Just don't need to add a dill pickle to it. And then whatever's happening there with the ketchup is a no for me as well. I would eat all of these. But that ketchup... And they're now yours. It's not like a fake ketchup taste. It's not like a real ketchup.
我喜欢法式洋葱薯片。只是不需要在里面加莳萝泡菜。至于后面那个番茄酱薯片，对我也一样是个“不”。我会吃所有这些。但那个番茄酱……它们现在归你了。这不像是假的番茄酱味道。也不像真的番茄酱。
I know, Phil. Don't judge. I can judge a little. Give me all... Give me all the fake... Don't judge a little. Give me all the fakie salty stuff. You know why I'm thrilled to see you both is because I want to invite you onto our podcast,
我知道，菲尔。别评判。我可以稍微评判一下。给我所有……给我所有那些假咸味的……别太评判。给我所有那些虚假的咸味零食。你知道我为什么很高兴见到你们俩吗，因为我想邀请你们上我们的播客，
Thinking Lunch. Now, we get to eat on your podcast, right? You get a real lunch. Not just chips like you give me. This is... We get a full lunch. To be fair, we didn't know you were stopping by. No excuse.
《思考午餐》。现在，我们可以在你们的播客上吃东西了吧？你们会吃一顿真正的午餐。不只是像你给我的那种薯片。这是……我们会有一顿完整的午餐。公平地说，我们不知道你要来。这不是借口。
You should always have lunch ready for anyone who might stop by. So true, Phil. Phil, thank you so much for stopping in to eat chips. We're going to go to break, but let's tell everyone about your podcast. Naked lunch. It's on the Stitcher Network. Naked lunch. It's on Stitcher.
你们应该随时为任何可能顺道拜访的人准备好午餐。说得太对了，菲尔。菲尔，非常感谢你顺道来吃薯片。我们要去休息一下，但让我们向大家介绍一下你的播客。光屁股午餐。它在Stitcher网络上。光屁股午餐。它在Stitcher上。
It's on Stitcher. Look, we have the same mugs. We have the same mugs. Check out Phil's podcast, Naked Lunch. With David Wilde. Yes. Where people eat full meals. Will you come?
它在Stitcher上。看，我们有同样的马克杯。我们有同样的马克杯。去看看菲尔的播客《光屁股午餐》。和大卫·怀尔德一起。是的。人们在那里吃全餐。你们会来吗？
Delicious meals. Yes. We'll come. Don't serve me anything in this area. In the chip, in the fake flavor. No fake ketchup. Yeah. Area.
美味的饭菜。是的。我们会去的。别在这个区域给我端上来。在薯片、虚假口味的区域。没有假番茄酱。对。区域。
No, we get lunch from... It can be a surprise for you. Or you get to pick where you want lunch from. I get it for you. Oh my gosh. You know we love a free meal. This is a good gig. We will be there.
不，我们的午餐来自……这可以是一个给你的惊喜。或者你可以选择你想从哪儿订午餐。我来为你买。噢，天哪。你知道我们喜欢免费的饭。这真是一份好差事。我们会去的。
There is such a thing as a free lunch. Ladies, I love you. Love you. Thanks, Phil. Thanks, Phil. Bye. Those of you that are huge, everybody loves Raymond fans. I love him because he created that with Ray Romano.
天下确实有免费的午餐。女士们，我爱你们。爱你们。谢谢，菲尔。谢谢，菲尔。再见。你们这些超级“人人都爱雷蒙德”的粉丝。我喜欢他，因为他和雷·罗马诺一起创作了那个节目。
That's right. He also had a show on Netflix called Somebody Feed Phil. And now he has the podcast, Naked Lunch. Which I guess, Jenna, we're going to go on and eat. I love free food, lady. I'm there. You never know who you're going to run into. Here at Ear Wolf.
没错。他在Netflix上还有一个节目叫《喂饱菲尔》。现在他有了播客《光屁股午餐》。我想，珍娜，我们要去那儿吃东西了。我喜欢免费食物，女士。算我一个。你永远不知道会在这里遇到谁。在Ear Wolf。
I know. I ran into Matt Besser the other day. Comedian Matt Besser. I did the movie Walk Hard with him. It's fun having a desk here. It really is. And people are back in the office. Well, listen, thank you from the bottom of our hearts for all of the things you sent.
我知道。我前几天碰到了马特·贝瑟。喜剧演员马特·贝瑟。我和他一起拍过电影《永不止步》。在这里有个办公桌真有意思。真的。而且大家又回办公室上班了。好吧，听着，我们发自内心地感谢你们寄来的所有东西。
We're going to stay on top of our mail now, I think, a little better. Yes. And really, what a wonderful two days that was opening up all of the mail, Angela. It put me in such a good mood and I loved feeling so connected to all of you all. Oh, same, Jenna. Same. We love you guys. Thank you so much for taking the time out to reach out to us.
我想我们以后处理邮件会更勤快一点了。是的。安吉拉，拆开所有邮件的那两天真是太美妙了。这让我心情大好，而且我喜欢和你们所有人都建立起这种紧密的联系。哦，我也是，珍娜。一样。我们爱你们。非常感谢你们抽空联系我们。
And we'll be back after this break with Costume Contest. This episode is going to start with a cold open where everyone is, well, they're kind of pranking Stanley because he's oblivious. Yeah, he goes to take a sip of his coffee, but he drinks some orange juice from Jim's coffee mug instead and he doesn't seem to notice the difference. This sets off a whole bunch of everyone in the office just acting strange around him to see if he will notice. I do have a question.
我们休息之后将带来“服装大赛”。这一集将以一个冷开场开始，大家都在……呃，他们有点在恶作剧斯坦利，因为他毫无察觉。是的，他去喝咖啡，但却喝了吉姆咖啡杯里的一杯橙汁，而且他似乎没有注意到区别。这引发了办公室里的一连串反应，每个人都在他身边表现得很奇怪，看他会不会注意到。我确实有个问题。
What is it? Why is Jim drinking orange juice out of a coffee mug? This was my question. I was like of all the ridiculous things in this cold open. To me, that is the most strange. I know. I mean, sure, Andy has no shirt on and Kevin is dressed like Phyllis, but orange juice in a coffee mug, Jim?
是什么？为什么吉姆要用咖啡杯喝橙汁？这就是我的问题。我想这可以说是这个冷开场里所有荒谬事情中最奇怪的了。我知道。我是说，当然，安迪没穿衬衫，凯文打扮得像菲利斯，但用咖啡杯喝橙汁，吉姆？
I do like the taste of orange juice in a coffee mug. There are certain things I like drinking from a mug. I like the taste of milk from a mug instead of a glass. Don't you find that the different container gives something to the liquid? I do, and I think orange juice in a coffee mug is disgusting. But I have such strong feeling. But I also like fake ketchup potato chips, so what do I know? I have a little tidbit from Randy Cordray at the very end of this cold open as Stanley's
我确实挺喜欢用咖啡杯喝橙汁的。有些东西我就是喜欢用杯子喝。我喜欢用杯子喝牛奶，而不是用玻璃杯。你不觉得不同的容器会给液体带来不同的风味吗？我觉得会，而且我觉得用咖啡杯装橙汁真的很恶心。但我的感觉就是这么强烈。不过我也喜欢番茄味薯片，所以我能懂什么呢？在这个开场白快结束的时候，关于斯坦利，兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）给了我一个小花絮
walking out. Is it about the pony? It's about the pony. I know that was from Bob Dunn's Animals, our go-to animal folks, and the pony's name was Bonsai. Bonsai. I had a Shetland pony. Are they big?
他正走出去。是关于那匹小马的吗？是关于那匹小马的。我知道那是来自鲍勃·邓恩动物公司（Bob Dunn's Animals）的，这是我们常用的动物供应商，那匹小马的名字叫盆栽。盆栽。我曾经有一匹设德兰矮马。它们很大吗？
No, they're tiny. Are they as tiny as the tiny pony in the cold open? Yes. Oh, some people let them in their house. I think Rainn Wilson has a Shetland pony that walks about his house. I think you're right. Yeah. This show opens with everyone in very festive Halloween attire.
不，它们很小。它们有开场白里那只小马那么小吗？是的。哦，有些人把它们养在家里。我想雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）家里就养了一匹会到处走的设德兰矮马。我想你是对的。是的。这一集一开始，每个人都穿着非常喜庆的万圣节服装。
They've really gone all out this time. Like truly, the costumes have gone all out, the decor, the prize for the contest will get there. Yeah. And Jenna, are you ready for a costume breakdown? Oh, oh, and with music, Sam, I'm liking this. Thank you, Sam. I looked at the shooting draft.
这次他们真的是全力以赴了。真的，服装简直是全情投入，装饰也是，比赛的奖品等下就会提到。对的。还有，珍娜，你准备好听服装大盘点了嘛？哦，哦，还有音乐，山姆，我喜欢这个。谢谢你，山姆。我看了拍摄剧本。
Here's how they describe everyone. Oscar is a disco guy. Angela is a penguin. Stanley is a samurai. Phyllis is Supreme Court Justice Elena Kagan. Creed is a mummy. Kevin is the filmmaker Michael Moore. Aaron is wearing a, quote, grotesque horror costume with a full latex mask.
他们是这样描述每个人的。奥斯卡是个迪斯科迷。安吉拉是一只企鹅。斯坦利是个武士。菲利斯是最高法院大法官埃лена·卡根（Elena Kagan）。克里德是个木乃伊。凯文是电影制作人迈克尔·摩尔（Michael Moore）。亚伦穿着一套，引述一下，“带有全乳胶面具的怪诞恐怖服装”。
Michael is dressed as the SNL character McGroober. Andy is Bill Compton from True Blood. Pam is olive oil. Dwight is the Scranton Strangler. Gabe is Lady Gaga. Daryl is a vampire. Toby is a hobo clown, and in parentheses it says a basic costume. Oh.
迈克尔打扮成周六夜现场（SNL）的角色麦克格鲁伯（McGroober）。安迪是《真爱如血》（True Blood）里的比尔·康普顿（Bill Compton）。帕姆是橄榄油。德怀特是斯克兰顿扼杀者。盖布是Lady Gaga。达里尔是个吸护鬼。托比是个流浪汉小丑，括号里写着这是一套基础服装。哦。
Ryan is Justin Bieber, and Kelly is Snooki from the reality TV show Jersey Shore. And Meredith is a waitress. I think maybe Snooki from True Blood, I'm not sure. Bob Vance is Dirty Harry. Hmm. Remember Clint Eastwood, Dirty Harry. Todd Packer is a pregnant nun, although that isn't in the script. Oh.
瑞安是贾斯汀·比伯（Justin Bieber），凯莉是真人秀节目《泽西海岸》（Jersey Shore）里的斯努基（Snooki）。梅雷迪思是个女服务员。我觉得可能是《真爱如血》里的斯努基，我不确定。鲍勃·范斯（Bob Vance）是肮脏的哈里（Dirty Harry）。嗯。还记得克林特·伊斯特伍德（Clint Eastwood）的《肮脏的哈里》吧。托德·帕克（Todd Packer）是一个怀孕的修女，虽然剧本里没有这一段。哦。
I don't know if they added that. And Jim does not have a costume. Danny Cordray does not have a costume. And in the course of this episode, five office workers will change costumes. Five? Yes. Oh. Kelly, Angela, Oscar, Michael, and, well, Jim.
我不知道是不是他们后来加上去的。吉姆没有穿服装。丹尼·科德雷（Danny Cordray）也没有穿服装。在这集节目中，将有五名办公室员工更换服装。五个？是的。哦。凯莉、安吉拉、奥斯卡、迈克尔，还有，呃，吉姆。
Oh, yes, of course. Oh. Okay. So, Jenna, I have to ask you, have you ever gone all out for Halloween? Because I kind of know your usual look. I've seen it. Yeah. I usually just do Halloween themed clothing.
哦，是的，当然。哦。好吧。那么，珍娜，我必须问你，你有没有为万圣节全力以赴过？因为我差不多知道你通常的打扮。我见过的。是的。我通常只穿万圣节主题的衣服。
So I've got a skeleton shirt. I've got my earrings that I wear. They're a little mummy and a little Frankenstein. But I did go all out one year. I really went all out and I even got Lee to dress up with me. What? And he is like even less of a dresser upper. In fact, this storyline with Jim and Pam of Pam wanting Jim to dress up reminded me of this.
所以我有一件骷髅衬衫。我戴着我常戴的耳环。那是一个小木乃伊和一个小弗兰肯斯坦。不过有一年我确实全力以赴了。我真的是全力以赴，甚至还让李跟我一起打扮。什么？而且他比我更不喜欢盛装打扮。事实上，吉姆和帕姆这条帕姆希望吉姆盛装打扮的故事线就让我想起了这事。
What was it? A few years ago, Lee and I were Mary Berry and Paul Hollywood from the Great British baking show. I remember that. It was so fun. We had the best time. I need pictures. We can definitely post a picture.
那是什麽？几年前，我和李打扮成《英国家庭烘焙大赛》（The Great British Baking Show）的玛丽·贝里（Mary Berry）和保罗·好莱坞（Paul Hollywood）。我记得那次。太有趣了。我们度过了最棒的时光。我需要照片。我们绝对可以发一张照片。
But that I would say, especially in recent memory, is the most all out I've ever gone. I feel like you're more of the costume person. You guys will do a whole thing. You've got several costumes from Target, you've got your donut that I've seen you wear a lot. I will say, I'm not someone that creates a whole cool costume and sew stuff and does elaborate stuff. I will just throw a donut over my own clothes. Yeah. And I'm usually a donut and Josh is a coffee.
但我要说的是，尤其是在最近的记忆中，那是我经历过的最全力以赴的一次。我觉得你更像是热衷于服装的人。你们会搞出一整套东西。你有好几套从塔吉特买来的服装，你那个甜甜圈我见你穿过很多次。我得说，我不是那种能制作出很酷的整套服装、缝制东西并搞得很复杂的人。我只会把一个甜甜圈套在自己的衣服外面。是的。我通常是个甜甜圈，乔希是个咖啡。
That's how we, one year we were eggs and bacon. I don't know why we have all these breakfast themes. But I have to ask you, when you were Mary Berry and Paul Hollywood, did people know who you guys were? When we posted the picture on Instagram, people knew. But in real life, I'm not sure. Okay. Because one year when I was a kid, probably, I don't know if I was around eight or nine. I went all out on a Halloween costume and no one knew who I was.
这就是我们，有一年我们打扮成鸡蛋和培根。我不知道为什么我们总是有这些早餐主题。但我必须问你，当你打扮成玛丽·贝里和保罗·好莱坞时，人们认得出你们是谁吗？当我们在Instagram上发了照片后，人们认出来了。但在现实生活中，我不确定。好吧。因为我小时候有一年，大概吧，我不知道我是八九岁左右。我在一套万圣节服装上全力以赴，结果没人知道我是谁。
I'm still tickled that my mom was so supportive of this because I'm sure my mom was like, what? Do you remember this SNL character, Gilda Radner would do, called Rosanna, Rosanna Dana? Yeah. She had a wig that went way out on either side of her head. It was like a big triangle. Yeah. A black triangle wig. She wore bright red lipstick and like a little suit and she'd be like, I'm Rosanna, Rosanna Dana.
我到现在还是觉得很好笑，我妈妈当时竟然那么支持我，因为我确信我妈当时心想：啥？你还记得吉尔达·拉德纳（Gilda Radner）在周六夜现场扮演过的一个角色吗，叫罗珊娜·罗珊娜·达娜（Rosanna Rosanna Dana）？是的。她有一个假发，两边头发向外伸得老远。就像一个大三角形。是的。一顶黑色的三角形假发。她涂着亮红色的口红，穿着一个小西装，然后会说，我是罗珊娜，罗珊娜·达娜。
And that's who I wanted to be for Halloween. So my mom got me a little suit and the triangle wig and bright red lipstick. And I think three people knew who I was. How old were you? I was like nine. You were a nine year old, Rosanna? Rosanna Dana. Rosanna Dana Dana.
那就是我万圣节想扮成的人。所以我妈给我弄了一套小西装、三角形假发和亮红色口红。我觉得当时有三个人认出了我是谁。你当时多大？我大概九岁。你是一个九岁的罗珊娜？罗珊娜·达娜。罗珊娜·达娜·达娜。
Rosanna Rosanna Dana. I know. I know. I mean, it kind of says everything you need to know about me. It really does. Well, speaking of another SNL character, Michael is dressed as McGroober and he is disarming a bomb. Yeah.
罗珊娜·罗珊娜·达娜。我知道。我知道。我的意思是，这几乎说明了你需要知道关于我的一切。确实如此。好吧，说到另一个周六夜现场的角色，迈克尔打扮成麦克格鲁伯，他正在拆除一枚炸弹。是的。
A really cute talking head. He's doing a whole bit. I had to look up McGiver because you know, McGroober is based on McGiver. McGiver was a TV show. Oh, I watched McGiver. I mean, I did too. He can do amazing things with like a paper clip and subchewed gum and like a stick. I had to look up McGiver just to refresh my memory, Jenna, and this tickled me.
一个非常可爱的单人访谈。他在演一整段。我不得不去查一下马基弗（MacGyver），因为你知道的，麦克格鲁伯是以马基弗为原型的。马基弗是一个电视节目。哦，我看过马基弗。其实我也看过。他能用回形针、嚼过的口香糖和一根小木棍做出惊人的事情。我为了恢复记忆特地去查了马基弗，珍娜，这把我逗乐了。
On McGiver's Wikipedia page, they list his most used items in each show. Are you ready? The things he uses to like disarm a bomb or like get into a car? Yes. Oh, please. His most used items are Swiss Army knife and he usually carries a roll of duct tape in his back pocket, but he's flattened it out to make it fit. Okay.
在马基弗的维基百科页面上，他们列出了他在每一集中最常用的物品。你准备好了吗？就是他用来拆炸弹或者溜进车里的那种东西？是的。哦，请讲。他最常用的物品是瑞士军刀，他的后裤兜里通常还卷着一卷强力胶带，但他把它压扁了以便塞进去。好吧。
I mean, I need to see a picture of that. Other items he always has on hand, an ID card, a Timex camper watch, strike anywhere matches, a few paper clips, chewing gum, flashlight, and a toolbox in his Jeep. Okay. That was why I said paper clip and chewing gum. I know, that's what we all remember. But when you listed those things, it actually doesn't sound as amazing everything he could do.
我的意思是，我需要看一张照片。他总是随身携带的其他物品还有：一张身份证件、一块天美时（Timex）野营手表、任何地方都能划着火的火柴、几个回形针、口香糖、手电筒，以及他吉普车里的工具箱。好吧。这就是为什么我刚才说回形针和口香糖。我知道，那是我们所有人都记得的。但当你把这些东西列出来时，他能做到的那些事情其实听起来并没有那么神奇了。
I mean, he had a full Swiss Army knife and a toolbox and some duct tape. I mean, who can't do amazing things with those three things? Now, hold up. The toolbox is in his car. Oh, so he has to get all the way back there. Right. But you know what he always has? What?
我的意思是，他有一把完整的瑞士军刀、一个工具箱还有一些强力胶带。我的意思是，谁用这三样东西做不出惊人的事情来？等等，打住。工具箱是在他的车里。哦，所以他得一路跑回车那儿去。没错。但你知道他身上一直带着什么吗？什么？
Gum, Swiss Army knife, and a smushed duct tape in his pocket. Well, okay. I'll be impressed. Well, now Pam has her talking head. She's dressed as olive oil. She's telling us that there is an excitement in the office because she has a prize for the best costume and everyone's excited about it. The prize is the 2011 Scranton Wilkes-Berry coupon book worth over $15,000 in savings.
口香糖、瑞士军刀，还有口袋里压扁的强力胶带。好吧，好吧。那我可要佩服了。好了，现在帕姆有她的单人访谈了。她打扮成橄榄油。她告诉我们办公室里弥漫着一种兴奋的气氛，因为她为最佳服装准备了一个奖品，大家都为此兴奋不已。这个奖品是2011年斯克兰顿-威尔克斯-巴里优惠券手册，价值超过15,000美元的优惠。
Pam is really animated in this episode. I want you to know that Pam had an alternate talking head and it was really fun to me. Was it the candy bag? Was it in the candy bag? Yes. And I remember doing it and that's why I wanted to bring it up. Here it is. Pam could have said everyone is bringing their A game to the costume contest in order to win
帕姆这一集里的表情真的很生动。我想让你们知道，帕姆还有一个备用的单人访谈，我觉得非常有趣。是那个糖果袋吗？是在糖果袋里吗？是的。我记得我拍过那段，这就是我想把它提出来的原因。它在这儿。帕姆本可以说每个人都在服装比赛中使出浑身解数，为了赢得
the super awesome prize, this coupon book. Okay. Wait. Is it coupon or coupon? I say coupon. Anyway, people will go nuts for these and I got my hands on one. It's worth $15,000 in savings, page after page of cute. Wait, do I say it like that?
这个超级棒的奖品，这本优惠券手册。等等。是念coupon还是coupon？我念coupon。不管怎样，大家为了这些东西都快疯了，我弄到了一本。它价值15,000美元的优惠，一页又一页的可爱。等等，我是这么说的吗？
Have I ever said that word out loud before? That was her talking head, was trying to figure out if she says coupon or coupon. So I was going to ask you, how do you say it? I say coupon. You say coupon. Yes, my husband loves a coupon. So, you know, there's always a coupon for something. Well, I can confirm in this episode, there are three people who say this word.
我以前有大声说过这个词吗？那是她的单人访谈，在纠结自己到底是念coupon还是coupon。所以我正想问你，你是怎么念的？我念coupon。你念coupon。是的，我丈夫非常喜欢优惠券。所以，你知道的，总有什么东西是有优惠券的。嗯，我可以证实这一集里有三个人说这个词。
You are one of them and you do say coupon. Woohoo. Oscar says this word twice. He says coupon. And interestingly enough, Pam says this word three times and she also says coupon. However, in 2011, coupons.com did a poll to see how English-speaking people pronounce this word and 57% of people say coupon. Where do they live?
你是其中之一，你确实念的是coupon。噢耶。奥斯卡把这个词说了两次。他说的是coupon。有趣的是，帕姆把这个词说了三次，她说的也是coupon。然而，在2011年，Coupons.com做过一次民意调查，看看说英语的人是怎么发音这个词的，57%的人念coupon。他们住在哪里啊？
Okay, primarily in the south and on the coasts. Coupon. Yeah. But then Cambridge University did a study on how English people pronounce it and that data showed that 61% of people say coupon. So I think we need our own poll. Coupon or coupon? All right.
是的，主要是在南方和沿海地区。Coupon。对。但后来剑桥大学对英国人如何发音做了一项研究，数据显示61%的人说coupon。所以我觉得我们需要自己的民意调查。Coupon还是coupon？好吧。
Where are we? Well, Dwight is the Scranton Strangler and he's going to sneak up behind Jim. Oh, I have a question about this. What is it? Dwight sees Pam and thinks she's mocking his mother. Right. Right? Mm-hmm.
我们在哪？嗯，德怀特是斯克兰顿扼喉杀手，他要悄悄走到吉姆身后。哦，我有个关于这个的问题。什么问题？德怀特看到帕姆，以为她在模仿他妈妈。对不对？对不对？嗯。
He says that Pam is only a third as beautiful as his mom and half her height. Mm-hmm. How tall is Dwight's mom? Very tall. How tall are you, Jenna? I'm five-six. Oh my gosh. That is hilarious.
他说帕姆的美貌只有他妈妈的三分之一，身高只有他妈妈的一半。嗯。德怀特妈妈有多高？非常高。詹娜，你有多高？我五尺六寸。哦天哪。太搞笑了。
I loved this olive oil costume. I'd like to say I had the best time. Alicia Raycraft, our costume designer, did all the costumes with her team for this episode. I thought they did a great job. Fantastic job, Alicia. She built my olive oil costume from scratch and she even sent me my fitting photo of me with all the pins in it. So we'll have to post that.
我很喜欢这套橄榄油服装。我想说我玩得很开心。我们的服装设计师艾莉西亚·雷克拉夫和她的团队为这一集制作了所有的服装。我觉得他们做得很好。干得漂亮，艾莉西亚。她从零开始制作了我的橄榄油服装，甚至还发给我一张带有所有别针的试穿照。所以我们得把它发出来。
That's awesome. And I loved the whole wig and all the everything. It was great. The wig would kind of bounce a little. Like the olive oil ponytail would kind of fliffly, fliffly. The only problem was that at lunch I couldn't lay down because they didn't want to take the wig on and off once it was on, it was on. Yeah.
太棒了。而且我很喜欢整个假发和所有的东西。太棒了。假发会有点弹跳。就像橄榄油马尾辫会有点蓬松、蓬松。唯一的麻烦是吃午饭时我不能躺下，因为他们不想把假发摘下来戴上去，一旦戴上就拿不下来了。对。
And so I couldn't put my head back even on like the couch or anything. Yeah. That was my problem when I had to be the nurse. Oh, they bobby pinned that thing into my head, the little hat. Pam really wants Jim to wear a Popeye costume. Yeah. She wants the whole family to be dressed up. He's not doing it.
所以我的头不能往后靠，连沙发什么的都不行。对。这就是我演护士时的烦恼。哦，他们用发夹把那个小帽子死死别在我头上。帕姆真的很想让吉姆穿大力水手服装。对。她想让全家人都盛装打扮。他才不干呢。
You know, he's not much of a costume guy. No. You know who is a costume guy? Apparently Gabe. Gabe goes all out as Lady Gaga. Yeah. We had a fan catch from Kayla M. in Washington, DC. Hi ladies, I was watching community season two episode 26 and Dean Pelton was dressed
你知道的，他不太喜欢穿化装服。不。你知道谁喜欢穿化装服吗？显然是盖布。盖布全力以赴扮演Lady Gaga。对。我们在华盛顿特区收到了一位叫凯拉·M的粉丝来信。嗨，女士们，我在看《废柴联盟》第二季第26集，其中佩尔顿院长打扮
up as Lady Gaga. This reminded me of the time the Gabe dressed as Lady Gaga in costume contest. So I decided to look up the air dates for both episodes and they premiered on the same night and they are dressed almost identically. That's hilarious. I looked up the pictures. Kayla's not the first person to notice this because all over Reddit there are these screenshots side by side of these two characters from the same night.
成Lady Gaga的样子。这让我想起了盖布在化装舞会那一集中打扮成Lady Gaga的样子。所以我决定查一下这两集的播出日期，它们是在同一晚首播的，而且他们的打扮几乎一模一样。太搞笑了。我查了照片。凯拉并不是第一个注意到这一点的人，因为在Reddit到处都是这两个角色在同一晚的并排截图。
Will you send me that? I sure will. Well, Gabe is holding a meeting with all of the sales team and he announces that the warehouse workers are now going to be able to make sales during their deliveries and that they will split the commissions with the sales team. This is actually really good news. The sales team doesn't seem to like this, but I thought it sounded pretty good because you'd almost have this surrogate sales person out selling on your route maybe being able
你能把那个发给我吗？没问题。好吧，盖布正在和全体销售团队开会，他宣布仓库员工现在可以在送货期间进行销售，并且他们将与销售团队平分佣金。这其实是个好消息。销售团队似乎不太喜欢这样，但我认为这听起来挺不错的，因为你差不多有了一个替补销售人员在你的路线上进行销售，或许能够
to tap into a need that you wouldn't know about. Well, there's a really funny deleted scenes. It's on the DVD where Michael is annoyed by this, you know? He feels like somehow they're, it's like they feel like somehow something's going to be taken away from them. So Michael makes this big speech and he says, would you rather have 50% of something or 100% of nothing? Exactly.
发掘出你可能不知道的需求。嗯，有一个非常搞笑的被删减片段。它在DVD里，迈克尔对此感到很恼火，你知道吗？他觉得某种程度上他们，就好像他们觉得某种程度上有什么东西要被抢走一样。所以迈克尔发表了一大演讲，他说，你宁愿要某种东西的50%还是什么都没有的100%？没错。
And everyone's like, well, when you put it that way, like Stanley's like, oh yeah, this is like passive income for me. Yeah. And Dwight's like, that's not helping Michael. Well, next Michael is going to enter Darryl's office and he's going to say to Darryl, hey, this idea is a lot like when you came to me with a while ago that I kind of squashed. And he's like, I blew it. I'm sorry.
然后大家都觉得，嗯，你这么一说，就像斯坦利说的那样，哦，对啊，这对我来说就像是管道收入。对。而德怀特则说，迈克尔，这毫无帮助。好吧，接下来迈克尔要走进达里尔的办公室，他对达里尔说，嘿，这个想法很像你前段时间向我提出但被我否决的那个。然后他说，我搞砸了。对不起。
Yeah. But Darryl is like, it's all right. We're cool. It's fine. I'm glad they're doing it. But you know, that's not where this story is going to end. No, it's not. In the kitchen, everyone is really excited about this coupon book.
对。但达里尔却说，没关系。我们很好。没问题。我很高兴他们在做这件事。但你知道的，这个故事可不是这样结束的。不，不是的。在厨房里，每个人都对这本优惠券小册子兴奋不已。
And Oscar is the only person all day long that is like, you guys, you realize this coupon book isn't actually worth $15,000. He's the only person who seems to understand how a coupon book works, which is that first you have to purchase something to get the savings. It's only worth what Pam paid for it. These coupon books cost money. Did you have these when you were growing up? We had these for fundraisers.
一整天下来，只有奥斯卡一个人说，各位，你们意识到这本优惠券小册子实际上并不值15,000美元吗？他是唯一一个似乎明白优惠券小册子是怎么运作的人，那就是首先你必须购买东西才能获得折扣。它只值帕姆花掉的钱。这些优惠券小册子是要花钱的。你们小时候有这个吗？我们以前为筹款活动买过这些。
Oh yeah. And I loved looking through them because you'd be like, oh, I can get free fries at McDonald's or you can get like buy one, get one free ticket to Six Flags. Yeah. Well, Danny is going to invite everyone to his bar. Super cute Danny Cordray co-owns a bar. I'm not attracted to it. I'm not.
哦，是的。我喜欢翻看它们，因为你会想，哦，我可以在麦当劳得到免费薯条，或者你可以得到六旗乐园的买一送一门票。对。好吧，丹尼要邀请大家去他的酒吧。超级可爱的丹尼·科德雷合伙经营了一家酒吧。我对此不感兴趣。我才不。
I'm not attracted to Danny Cordray bar owner with the super ironic name public school. You know, Oscar doesn't seem impressed either. Oscar loves it. He goes public school. That's hilarious. A plus. I felt like he was being snarky. No.
我对拥有这个超级讽刺的名字“公立学校”的酒吧老板丹尼·科德雷一点也不感兴趣。你知道，奥斯卡看起来也没被打动。奥斯卡很喜欢。他说公立学校。太搞笑了。给个好评。我觉得他在说风凉话。不。
No. You think that's genuine? I went to the script. And? The stage direction is that Oscar is like clearly like trying to flirt. Oh, like he's enamored? Yes, he's enamored. And then as he says, it's hilarious.
不。你觉得那是真心实意的？我去看了剧本。然后呢？舞台说明是奥斯卡明显在试图调情。哦，就像他被迷住了？是的，他被迷住了。然后当他说出这句话时，太搞笑了。
Then he's like embarrassed and then he's like a plus and he kind of backs away. Well, let me say that makes sense to me. But I think he's faking his admiration of the bar to flirt. I think down deep Oscar and I feel the same way. Okay. Well, I wanted to know if there really is a public school bar. I went online and Jenna, there is a public school restaurant and bar in Sherman Oaks. Not too far from where we filmed.
然后他觉得很尴尬，接着他又说了一个赞，然后他往后退了退。好吧，我得说这对我来说很合情合理。但我认为他是假装对酒吧赞赏来调情。我觉得骨子里我和奥斯卡有同感。好吧。嗯，我想知道到底有没有公立学校酒吧。我上网查了一下，詹娜，谢尔曼奥克斯真的有一家叫公立学校的餐厅和酒吧。离我们拍摄的地方不远。
Oh my gosh. I wonder if that's where they got the name because there's not one in Scranton, right? There's not. I looked. What kind of stuff do they serve? It looks like bar food. American fare. Yeah.
哦天哪。我想知道他们是不是从那里得到的灵感，因为斯克兰顿没有这种店，对吧？没有。我查过。他们供应什么类型的食物？看起来像是酒吧食物。美式餐点。对。
All right. There you go. There is a public school bar. Next up, there's some gossip in the break room. There really is. I mean, just people just chitty chatting about Jim and Pam and Danny Cordray. They clearly needed a little drama. They needed something.
好吧。就是这样。确实有公立学校酒吧。接下来，休息室里有些八卦。确实有。我是说，大家都在闲聊吉姆、帕姆和丹尼·科德雷的事。他们显然需要一点戏剧性。他们需要点乐子。
Everyone is still stuck on the fact that Pam dated Danny. Yeah. They're like discussing, is Pam going to choose Jim or Danny? She's married and has a child with Jim. They went to the wedding. They're happy. Like, what is going on? Dwight interrupts everyone and says, listen, Pam will choose whichever guy sent most matches
大家依然纠结于帕姆和丹尼约会过这件事。对。他们一直在讨论，帕姆会选择吉姆还是丹尼？她已经结婚了，还和吉姆有了孩子。他们去参加了婚礼。他们很幸福。所以，这到底是怎么回事？德怀特打断了所有人并说道，听着，帕姆会选择那个气味最像她父亲的男人
that of her father. And then he's like, does anyone know what her dad smelled like? And Phyllis seems like she's going to start to remember what Pam's dad smelled like. Oh my gosh. Angela, did you look up something about pheromones and dating? Did you? Well, I recalled a study that I read about years ago about women and the scent of a man that they are most attracted to.
然后他说，有人知道她爸爸是什么气味吗？菲利斯看起来似乎开始回想起帕姆爸爸的气味了。哦天哪。安吉拉，你查过关于信息素和约会的事情吗？你查了吗？嗯，我想起多年前读过的一项研究，关于女性和她们最被吸引的男性的气味。
And so I looked up the details to make sure I remembered it correctly and I did. Do you want to hear it? I mean, I really do. Okay. Give me all the men sent info. Okay. So in general, women really do seem to pick their mate based on smell as do other animals. This is a thing.
所以我查了细节，确保我没记错，确实如此。你想听吗？我是说，我真的很想听。好吧。把所有关于男性气味的信息都告诉我吧。好吧。总的来说，女性确实倾向于根据气味来选择伴侣，其他动物也是如此。这是真的。
Okay. You have these genes called the major histocompatibility complex or MHC. And those genes, I guess, play a role in your immune system and fighting disease. And this is what we're smelling for. We're smelling men for their MHC gene. Okay. So they did a study at the University of Liverpool. Okay.
好吧。你们有一些被称为主要组织相容性复合体或MHC的基因。我想这些基因在你的免疫系统和对抗疾病方面发挥着作用。而这正是我们用鼻子寻找的东西。我们在男性的气味中寻找MHC基因。好吧。所以他们在利物浦大学做了一项研究。好吧。
They recruited 110 women between the ages of 18 and 35. And they gave these women t-shirts that men had worn overnight and it had different men's scents on them. The women never saw what the men looked like. They just smelled the shirts and then they had to rate them on their pleasantness, like which ones were you most attracted to? And they asked the women based on the smell, who would you most pick as a long-term partner? Right.
他们招募了110名年龄在18到35岁之间的女性。他们给这些女性穿了男性穿过一整夜的T恤，上面有不同男性的气味。这些女性从未见过这些男性的长相。她们只是闻了闻T恤，然后必须根据气味的好闻程度对它们进行评分，比如你最被哪一种气味吸引？他们还根据气味询问这些女性，你会选择谁作为长期伴侣？对。
Okay. Which t-shirt are you picking? They found that the women tended to be attracted to people with an MHC that was dissimilar to their own. And they concluded that's because it would be beneficial to mate with someone who is most genetically different from you because you're less likely to share genetic defects that you would pass along to your children. Oh my God, the body is so cool.
好吧。你会选哪件T恤？他们发现，女性往往会被MHC与自己不同的异性所吸引。他们的结论是，与在基因上与你差异最大的人交配是有好处的，因为你们不大可能拥有共同的基因缺陷并遗传给孩子。哦天哪，人体太奇妙了。
Isn't that crazy? That's cool. But here's what they were really studying during this test. What? They were studying. There's a twist? There's a twist. What are you talking about?
是不是很疯狂？这太酷了。但他们在这次测试中真正研究的是什么？什么？他们在研究。还有一个反转？有一个反转。你在说什么？
These ladies just signed up to smell t-shirts. Well, they wanted to test the effect of birth control pills on our ability to smell out a good mate. So at first, none of the women were taking birth control and they could smell better. They could smell out a mate that was dissimilar from them. And then when they got on birth control, it changed adult their senses or something. It changed who they were attracted to. Suddenly, women were attracted to the smells of men who were more genetically similar.
这些女士只是报名来闻T恤的。好吧，他们想测试避孕药对我们寻找好伴侣的嗅觉能力的影响。起初，这些女性都没有服用避孕药，她们的嗅觉更好。她们能闻出与自己基因差异大的伴侣。然后当她们开始服用避孕药时，它改变了成年人的感官还是什么的。它改变了她们被吸引的对象的类型。突然间，女性开始被基因更相似的男性的气味所吸引。
In general, the effects of the study said if you meet someone while taking birth control and then you stop it, or if you meet someone not taking birth control and you start it, it might affect your attraction to them because you smell different. You're attracted to a different thing. That's fascinating. There was a study in psychological science of 365 couples that found that women who went on the pill during a relationship were now suddenly less sexually satisfied than women who had been consistently on the pill or never on the pill.
总的来说，该研究的影响表明，如果你在服用避孕药期间遇到了某人，然后你停药了，或者如果你在没有服用避孕药时遇到了某人并开始服药，这可能会影响你对他们的吸引力，因为你闻起来变了。你被不同的东西吸引了。这太迷人了。《心理科学》杂志对365对伴侣进行了一项研究，发现如果在恋爱期间开始服用避孕药的女性，现在突然对性生活不如那些一直吃避孕药或从不吃避孕药的女性那么满意。
All right, but here is the other thing. Of course, I had to Google this thing that Dwight says about Pam picking the person who smells most like her father. That's where I thought you were going. Well, if you can believe it, there was another study, another t-shirt smelling study. New ladies came in and smelled some new t-shirts. This was published in the medical journal Nature Genetics. This study found out something new.
好吧，但还有一件事。当然，我不得不谷歌搜索德怀特关于帕姆选择气味最像她父亲的人的说法。我以为你要去那儿呢。好吧，如果你敢相信的话，还有另一项研究，又一项闻T恤的研究。新女士们进来闻了一些新T恤。这发表在医学期刊《自然遗传学》上。这项研究发现了新东西。
What? New t-shirt smelling info. Yes, women were attracted to men who were genetically different. However, it found that they were attracted to men who were genetically similar in one way, otherwise different. Do you know what the one way was? I have no idea. They smelled like their fathers.
什么？关于闻新T恤的新信息。是的，女性被基因不同的男性吸引。然而，研究发现，她们被在某个方面基因相似、但在其他方面不同的男性吸引。你知道这唯一的一个方面是什么吗？我完全不知道。他们闻起来像她们的父亲。
That's right. The t-shirts they loved most were worn by men who also had the same MHC genetic code to smell disease fighting genetics as their dads. Well, Dwight, you got it right. He got it right. I guess Jim smells like Pam's dad. Yeah. And thank you to all the ladies who smelled shirts and to the men who wore them who were
没错。她们最喜欢的T恤是由那些拥有与她们父亲相同的MHC基因代码（即抗击疾病的遗传密码）的男性穿过的。好吧，德怀特，你猜对了。他猜对了。我猜吉姆闻起来像帕姆的爸爸。对。感谢所有闻T恤的女士们，以及那些穿了T恤却在实验期间
not allowed to smoke, use cologne, deodorant, half sex or eat certain foods during the experiment. We thank you. Everyone go home and smell your mate. Well this is going to lead to a Jim and Pam talking head where we learn that four years ago, while Jim was in Stanford dating Karen, Pam went on two dates with Danny Cordray. And you know what? It wasn't a big deal. They had two dates.
不准抽烟、使用古龙水、除臭剂、发生性行为或吃特定食物的男士们。我们感谢你们。大家回家去闻闻你们的伴侣吧。好吧，这将引出一个吉姆和帕姆的对镜头独白，我们了解到四年前，当吉姆在斯坦福与凯伦约会时，帕姆和丹尼·科德雷约会了两次。你知道吗？这没什么大不了的。他们约会了两次。
No big deal. Right? Yeah. He didn't call her back. Whatever. Yeah. Well, this isn't sitting well with Andy and Kevin. No, for some reason, they think that they can't go to Danny's party at public school
没什么大不了的。对吧？对。他没有回她电话。随他便吧。对。好吧，这让安迪和凯文很不痛快。不，出于某种原因，他们认为他们不能去丹尼在公立学校举行的派对
because they need to show support for Jim and Pam. Yeah. And they're really bummed because they don't get invited to a lot of parties, you guys. They don't. This, Kevin and Andy talking head has a lot of tooth play. Did you see the tooth play? The fake teeth in and out? The in and out.
因为他们需要表示对吉姆和帕姆的支持。对。他们真的很沮丧，因为他们不常受邀去参加派对，伙计们。确实没有。凯文和安迪的这段对镜头独白有很多牙齿的戏份。你看到那个牙齿秀了吗？假牙戴上又取下？进进出出。
Andy, as this vampire character- Bill Compton. He's right. From True Blood. Yeah. He is going to use those plastic Dracula teeth like nobody's business. In every scene, they're in, they're out, they're in, they're out. I wanted to find out who invented the plastic Dracula teeth. I went down a rabbit hole and I never found out.
安迪，作为这个吸血鬼角色——比尔·康普顿。他说得对。出自《真爱如血》。对。他会把那副塑料德古拉假牙用得淋漓尽致。在每一个场景里，它们戴进去，拿出来，戴进去，拿出来。我想查查是谁发明了塑料德古拉假牙。我深入研究了一番，却根本没有找到答案。
We'll never know. I don't know who invented them. You can get them everywhere, though. That I did find out. We already knew that. Well, I think we should go to break because when we come back, Madge from the warehouse is going to make a sale. Yeah.
我们永远不会知道了。我不知道是谁发明的。不过你到处都能买到。我确实查到了这一点。我们早就知道了。好吧，我想我们该去休息一下了，因为当我们回来时，仓库的马奇要完成一笔销售了。对。
And Michael really wants everyone to congratulate Daryl. He really does. And we're going to find out some information. Oh. Well, we are back and like Angela said before the break, Jim has announced that Madge from the warehouse just made her first sale. Well, Michael feels bad because he feels like Daryl has never gotten credit for this idea and clearly the idea is going well.
而且迈克尔非常想让大家祝贺达里尔。他真的很想。而且我们会发现一些信息。哦。好吧，我们回来了，就像安吉拉在休息前说的那样，吉姆宣布仓库的马奇刚刚完成了她的第一笔销售。好吧，迈克尔觉得很内疚，因为他觉得达里尔从来没有因为这个创意而受到赞誉，而且显然这个创意进展得很顺利。
So he asked Erin to call Daryl on speakerphone. Oh boy. Why was that so hard for Erin? Well, it's like Pam said, like she was able to call him. She hit the button. She just can't hang up. Yeah. It's like same button you pressed before.
所以他让艾琳用免提给达里尔打电话。哦，天哪。为什么对艾琳来说这这么难？好吧，就像帕姆说的，她明明能给他打电话。她按了按钮。她就是挂不了断。对。就像你之前按的是同一个按钮一样。
Erin ends up sitting on the phone to try to hang it up. Well Daryl reluctantly comes out and Michael really blames corporate that they stole this idea from Daryl and Gabe is like, no, no, corporate didn't steal anything. Daryl told me the idea. I took it to corporate giving Daryl full credit and they liked his idea. In fact, let's give Daryl that round of applause. Yeah. Now Michael is mad that Daryl went over his head.
艾琳最后居然坐在电话上试图把它挂断。好吧，达里尔不情愿地出来了，而迈克尔真的在指责公司从达里尔那里偷了这个创意，盖布却说，不，不，公司没有偷任何东西。达里尔把这个想法告诉了我。我把它带给了公司，并把全部功劳归于达里尔，他们很喜欢他的想法。事实上，让我们给达里尔热烈鼓掌。对。现在迈克尔生气了，因为达里尔越级汇报了。
He's peeved. That's right. Dwight tells Michael that this kind of behavior is going to make his job obsolete. Like if people can just go around Michael straight to corporate, then what is Michael's job really? This is going to make Michael spiral out. Meanwhile, Kevin is going to walk up to Danny Cordray at the water cooler and he's going to smack him on the butt. Did you catch that?
他很生气。没错。德怀特告诉迈克尔，这种行为会让他的工作变得毫无用处。如果人们可以绕过迈克尔直接去找公司，那迈克尔的工作到底还有什么意义？这会让迈克尔情绪彻底失控。与此同时，凯文走到饮水机旁的丹尼·科德雷身边，狠狠拍了他的屁股。你看到了吗？
I did. That's how he gets his attention. Yeah. I did. And I also caught Timothy Oliphant as Danny looking back at him like, what's happening? What are you doing? They need his attention because Andy and Kevin are going to explain that as much as they would like to come to public school for this party, they're going to bow out.
我看到了。这就是他引起别人注意的方式。对。我看到了。我还看到扮演丹尼的蒂莫西·奥利芬特回头看着他，那表情仿佛在说，怎么回事？你在干嘛？他们需要引起他的注意，因为安迪和凯文要解释说，尽管他们非常想去公立学校参加这个派对，但他们要退出了。
Because Jim and Pam asked them not to go is what they say. Danny's going to talk to Jim and Pam, but Kevin's like, don't say me and Andy talk to you or we'll kill you or you'll be dead. Yeah. I mean, what is going on? Kelly is going to arrive back to work in a new costume. It's very elaborate. I looked in the shooting draft and here's what it said.
因为吉姆和帕姆让他们不要去，他们是这么说的。丹尼要跟吉姆和帕姆谈谈，但凯文却说，别说是我和安迪跟你谈的，否则我们杀了你，或者你会死的。对。我是说，这到底是怎么回事？凯莉穿着一身新化装服回公司上班了。非常精致。我在拍摄剧本里查了一下，上面是这么写的。
Kelly walks in with some shopping bags. She is an elaborate sexy clown. That's what it is. I wondered, I thought maybe she was being a pop star from a music video or something. She's an elaborate sexy clown. Okay. She also shares about how much she spent on this costume. It's in deleted scenes.
凯莉拎着几个购物袋走进来。她是一个精致的性感小丑。就是这样。我很好奇，我还以为她是在扮演某个音乐视频里的流行歌星之类的。她是一个精致的性感小丑。好吧。她还分享了她在这套服装上花了好大一笔钱。这在被删减片段里。
Let's hear it. My costume costs $600. If I had the coupon book, it would have cost 20% less than that, which is why I need that coupon book. By the way, we have another coupon. No one has said coupon. Well, now Angela is peeved. She says, Kelly, you cannot change costumes in the middle of the day, Pam.
我们听听看。我的化装服花了600美元。如果我有那本优惠券小册子，它就会比原价便宜20%，这就是为什么我需要那本优惠券小册子。顺便说一句，我们有另一张优惠券。没有人说过coupon。好吧，现在安吉拉生气了。她说，凯莉，你不能在白天中间换衣服，帕姆。
She's out. This leads to a back and forth where Oscar jumps in. I want you guys to know I improvised the line. Yeah. Shut it, Oscar. Pam. Nice. I also wanted to share with you guys, we could not get through my talking head in this
她被淘汰了。这导致了一来一回的争论，奥斯卡也插话了。我想让你们知道，这句台词是我即兴发挥的。对。闭嘴，奥斯卡。帕姆。太棒了。我还想跟你们分享的是，我们在拍我戴着这个企鹅头套的对镜头独白时，根本没办法顺利完成。
penguin costume. I can see why. It's so funny. You're such an angry penguin. You're so mad. The penguin costume was so incredibly comfortable, but the way the beak went up and over my forehead kind of limited my side vision. Even when I turn to you, when I say, shut it, Oscar, Pam, if you look at how I turn,
我能理解为什么。太搞笑了。你是个多么生气的企鹅啊。你太生气了。企鹅服装超级舒服，但喙向上延伸盖住我额头的方式有点限制了我的侧面视线。甚至当我转向你，当我说“闭嘴，奥斯卡，帕姆”时，如果你看我转身的方式，
it looks like I have a crick in my neck, but it's just the way the penguin head set on my forehead. Anyway, Dean and I were cracking up so much in this talking head. I kind of felt like we had to hear it. Yay. This is an amazing prize. I mean, I don't even want to give Pam a compliment because she's so rough, but she did a good job.
看起来我的脖子好像落枕了，但其实只是企鹅头套戴在我额头上的方式导致的。不管怎样，迪安和我在拍这段独白时笑得不行。我觉得我们还是得听听这个。太棒了。这是一个了不起的奖品。我是说，我甚至都不想夸帕姆，因为她太粗鲁了，但她做得真好。
I really want that coupon book. I love when you're like the rough. She's so rough. That was so much fun to do. I loved that penguin costume. It was like wearing pajamas all day minus the way the head fit. Everything else was awesome. Well, next up Dwight is, what is he doing?
我真的很想要那本优惠券小册子。我喜欢你表现得很粗鲁的样子。她太粗鲁了。拍这一段太有趣了。我很喜欢那套企鹅服装。就像整天穿着睡衣一样，除了头套不太合适。其他一切都太棒了。好吧，接下来德怀特在做什么？
He's throwing magnets away in the trash. He doesn't like magnets that are too busy that have too much going on. Yeah. They're interesting enough. You don't have to tart them up with some design at 10 minutes, 33 seconds. I'd like to point out a personal Halloween decoration. What? I have the same spooky spider that's hanging over the table in the kitchen.
他在把磁铁扔进垃圾桶。他不喜欢太花哨、有太多花样（内容）的磁铁。对。它们本身已经够有趣了。你不需要在10分33秒时用某种设计来哗众取宠。我想指出一个个人的万圣节装饰。什么？厨房桌子上方挂着的那只可怕的蜘蛛跟我的一模一样。
I decorate with it every Halloween. Spooky spider. Michael is watching a conversation between Kevin and Gabe. It's pretty animated and Michael is just freaking out. He thinks everyone is going over his head, around his head. What do y'all, what do y'all also say, what do you call when someone takes you from the back and Dwight's like, no, no, no. Yeah.
我每个万圣节都用它来装饰。可怕的蜘蛛。迈克尔正在看凯文和盖布之间的谈话。场面相当活跃，迈克尔整个人都快崩溃了。他觉得每个人都在越过他、绕过他。你们怎么说，你们怎么称呼那种从背后对你下手的人，然后德怀特说，不，不，不。对。
What is it? Let's take them from behind. Michael thinks everyone's going to Gabe behind his back. So he storms in to this conversation and really lays into Kevin. Kevin is so upset and apologetic. Shout out to Brian Baumgartner who crushed this moment. I agree. He's such a good performer.
是什么？我们从背后攻击他们。迈克尔认为每个人都在背地里绕过盖比去找他。所以他冲进这场对话，狠狠地训斥了凯文。凯文非常难过和抱歉。向布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgartner）致敬，他完美地诠释了这一刻。我同意。他真的是个很好的表演者。
So good. It turns out that he was just suggesting some Lady Gaga moves, but in the future he'll tell Michael first. There's a really great robot move. He was going to show him. Yeah. And Michael's like, just don't let it happen again. And Kevin is like, no way, Jose.
太棒了。原来他只是在建议一些Lady Gaga的舞步，但以后他会先告诉迈克尔。还有一个非常棒的机器人舞步。他本打算展示给他的。是的。迈克尔说，别再发生这种事了。凯文则说，没门，何塞。
Yeah. I did look in the shooting draft. The fuck you gave was not in the script. I suspected it was not. And the reason why is because they cut out of that so fast, because I'm sure everyone cracked up after he did it. Next up, we're in the conference room with Danny, Jim, and Pam, and they're just having a big laugh over this crazy notion that Jim and Pam wouldn't want people to go to his
是的。我查了拍摄剧本。那句“他妈的你给的”并不是剧本里的。我猜它就不在。原因是因为他们切出那个镜头太快了，因为我确信大家在他做完之后都笑喷了。接下来，我们在会议室里，有丹尼、吉姆和帕姆，他们正在对吉姆和帕姆不想让大家去他
party. Jenna, you are so great in this scene. You are so good in it. I rewatched it a few times. I even recorded it when you say, no, actually, it was two dates. We had a plan for a third. We have to hear it. It's too good.
派对这个疯狂的想法大笑。珍娜，你在这场戏里演得太棒了。你演得太好了。我重看了好几遍。甚至在你说“不，其实那是两个约会。我们原本计划有第三个”时录了下来。我们必须听听。太精彩了。
It was two. Was it two? I thought it was three. No, we had plans for a third, but then, I don't know, you'd have a call in the back. Oh. You can't. Well, that does not sound like me. Yeah.
是两个。是两个吗？我以为是三个。不，我们计划有第三个，但后来，我不知道，你在后面接了个电话。哦。你不能。好吧，听起来可不像我。是的。
It was so. That's what happened. So awkward. But you do that thing. You and I do this in real life. Sometimes when things are awkward, we go, well, somebody didn't bring their homework today. Yes, exactly.
太……事情就是这样。太尴尬了。但你做了那个动作。你和我现实生活中也会这样。有时事情很尴尬时，我们会说，好吧，今天有人没带作业来。是的，完全是这样。
It's like, uh-oh, I feel uncomfortable. I guess I shouldn't have backed into your car, but it, but it, burp. It was not in the shooting draft stage direction for you to be sing-songy or do any of that. That was all your choice, and I thought it was fantastic. Aw, thank you, lady. Yeah. Well, there's one other time I love. I'll bring it up later.
就像是，呃-哦，我觉得不舒服。我想我不该倒车撞到你的车，但是，但是，嗝。拍摄剧本的舞台指导里并没有要求你用唱歌的语调或做任何这些动作。这完全是你的选择，我觉得太棒了。噢，谢谢你，亲爱的。是的。好吧，还有一次我很喜欢。我待会儿提出来。
You're so good. You're so good in this episode. I really loved it. I have to say I found Pam absolutely adorable in this episode, and I'm very, very proud of my performance. If I could toot my own horn for a moment, and I'll use a voice to do it. Toot it. Well, Michael is going to confront Daryl.
你太棒了。你在这集里太棒了。我真的很喜欢。我不得不说，我觉得帕姆在这集里绝对可爱极了，我为自己的表现感到非常自豪。如果我能自我吹嘘一下的话，我会用一种声音来表达。吹嘘吧。好吧，迈克尔要去找达里尔对峙了。
He says the chain of command is crumbling. He just made Kevin cry. Yeah. And Daryl says, I'm sorry you're upset. And then Michael is like, well, thank you for your apology. I'd like this apology in front of everyone. And Daryl says, I'm not apologizing to you. Yeah, he's like, you made a bad call.
他说指挥系统正在崩溃。他刚刚把凯文弄哭了。是的。达里尔说，我很抱歉你很难过。然后迈克尔说，好吧，谢谢你的道歉。我希望这个道歉能在所有人面前说。达里尔说，我才不向你道歉。是的，他说，你做出判断失误的决定。
Yeah. I fixed it. There is a line in this scene that I thought could go on a Halloween mug. You tell me if you like it, Angela. Okay. It's a Michael Scott quote, Halloween should be a day in which we honor monsters and not be mad at each other. That's a good one.
是的。我解决了。这场戏里有一句台词，我觉得可以印在万圣节马克杯上。安吉拉，你告诉我你喜不喜欢。好的。这是一句迈克尔·斯科特的金句，万圣节应该是我们向怪物致敬而不是互相生气的一天。这句不错。
Right? And then it has like little monster people on it. Mm-hmm. Little Frankenstein and a mummy and everything. It's cute, right? I like it. Thank you. One of my favorite lines from the whole entire episode is coming up.
对吧？然后上面还有一些小怪物人。嗯-嗯。小弗兰肯斯坦、木乃伊什么的。很可爱，对吧？我很喜欢。谢谢。整集里我最喜欢的台词之一就要来了。
What's that? It made me laugh so hard. Is it Ryan? No. Oh. Andy says, Suke, which is a character name on True Blood. And then he takes out his teeth and says, Bill Compton from True Blood. He says that to Stanley.
是什么？把我逗得哈哈大笑。是瑞恩吗？不是。哦。安迪说了苏克（Suke），这是《真爱如血》里的一个角色名。然后他拿假牙出来说，我是《真爱如血》里的比尔·康普顿。他对斯坦利说了这句话。
Stanley looks at him and says, how many frickin' vampires am I supposed to care about these days? I loved that line. That was so good. This is very similar to the person who doesn't want to give a standing ovation. Yeah. How many vampires? Seriously?
斯坦利看着他说，这些天我到底要在乎多少个该死的吸血鬼？我超爱这句台词。太棒了。这和那个不想起立鼓掌的人非常相似。是的。到底有多少个吸血鬼？说真的？
Mm-hmm. Well, we have our second costume change. Oscar has taken off his disco guy ensemble and he is now just a rational consumer. Mm-hmm. He's so proud of this. He does. And that's when Ryan has his snarky line. So much Ryan snark.
嗯-嗯。好吧，我们迎来了第二套服装。奥斯卡脱下了他的迪斯科舞者行头，现在他只是一个理性的消费者。嗯-嗯。他对此感到非常骄傲。他确实如此。就在这时，瑞恩说了一句讽刺的话。太多的瑞恩式讽刺了。
Yeah. He's like, yeah, I heard you say it to Phyllis. It's a great line. It's a great one. Yeah. Yeah. Pam is going to start passing out the ballots for the costume contest and she explains that you cannot vote for yourself.
是的。他说，对啊，我听见你对菲利斯这么说了。这句台词太棒了。真是一句好台词。是的。是的。帕姆要开始发放服装比赛的选票了，她解释说你不能给自己投票。
Mm-hmm. That's how this is going to work. We're going to have our third costume change. Michael is going to show up dressed as a warehouse worker. He has Daryl's shirt on. He's Daryl. Yeah. And he's a jerk.
嗯-嗯。事情就是这样。我们将迎来第三套服装。迈克尔穿着仓库工人的服装出现。他穿着达里尔的衬衫。他是达里尔。是的，他是个混蛋。
Yeah. Pam says this is a bad idea. When has this ever worked for you? That's a line I appreciated. Michael says never. He's so bummed out that Daryl went behind us back to Gabe and he's just acting like an asshole. He really is.
是的。帕姆说这是个坏主意。这什么时候对你有用过？我很欣赏这句台词。迈克尔说从来没有。他太沮丧了，因为达里尔背着他去找盖比，而他现在的表现就像个混蛋。他真的是。
The costume parade contest begins. I want you guys to know if you go to the DVD on deleted scenes, there's an extended cut of this and you see pretty much every single person do the catwalk. I think that this was based on our real life costume contest that we did every Halloween with our crew. Yeah. I recently got a picture of me and Vartan judging the Halloween costume contest. One year I got to be the guest judge.
服装游行比赛开始了。我想让你们知道，如果你去看DVD上的被删片段，里面有一个加长版，你会看到几乎每个人都走了T台。我认为这是基于我们每年万圣节和剧组一起举办的真实服装比赛。是的。我最近得到了我和瓦尔坦担任万圣节服装比赛评委的照片。有一年我成了特邀评委。
He would always judge and he would have a guest judge and I got to do it and I'll give that to you, Angela, so you can post it. It's really cool. I love it. Well, we're going to have our fourth costume change, which is Angela has gone from the penguin to the sexy nurse. She has a talking head where she says, I don't like your tone. Look.
他总是担任评委，并且会有一个特邀评委，我有幸做过一次，安吉拉，我会把它给你，这样你就可以发出来了。真的很酷。我太喜欢了。好吧，我们要迎来第四套服装了，那就是安吉拉从企鹅变成了性感护士。她有一个独白镜头，在镜头里她说，我不喜欢你的语气。听着。
You're going to be pulled out of all the other costumes. Okay. I think we all live in the real world here. Let's not pretend to be unaware of what sells in this office. Let me say as your best friend being on set with you while you wore that costume, it was very skimpy. I kind of can't believe it made it on the air. You were wearing like nothing.
你们会被排除在所有其他服装之外的。好吧。我想我们都生活在现实世界里。让我们不要假装不知道在这个办公室里什么卖得动。作为你的最好朋友，在片场陪着你穿那套衣服，我必须说，那真的很暴露。我有点不敢相信它能在电视上播出。你几乎什么都没穿。
I truly could not bend over. No. I had little mesh biker shorts on because didn't want to ruin the mystery. I had little high heels on and these stockings, a tiny little dress, and then Alicia brought me a box of the chicken cutlet boobs and we played with a few different sizes. I want you to know the first size that they had for me, I would have looked like Dolly Parton. I love you, Dolly.
我真的弯不下腰。没有。我穿着小网眼骑行短裤，因为不想破坏神秘感。我穿着小高跟鞋和长筒袜，一条极短的小裙子，然后艾莉西亚给我拿了一盒鸡排假胸，我们试玩了好几种不同尺寸。我想让你们知道，他们给我准备的第一种尺寸，我看起来会像多莉·帕顿。我爱你，多莉。
I wasn't ready to be full Dolly Parton. I said, can we scale back on the cutlet size? Well, the very odd thing was that they recycled the nurse costume. Yeah. The same costume that Jackie DeBotton wore when she held up the big check for science. Yeah. It was the exact same one. I think they just had to trim the length a little for me.
我还没准备好完全成为多莉·帕顿。我说，我们能把胸垫尺寸缩小一点吗？好吧，最奇怪的是他们循环利用了那套护士服装。是的。杰基·德博顿（Jackie DeBotton）举着科学巨额支票时穿的就是同一套衣服。是的。完全是一模一样的。我想他们只是帮我把长度稍微修短了一点。
Well they trimmed it too much. They might have. They really did. It was so short. I will tell you that Kim Ferry, who did my hair on the show, we had so much fun because I got to have fun sassy hair. Just so you know, I would take the penguin costume over that any day because the penguin costume was like wearing a sleeping bag.
好吧，他们修得太多了。他们可能真的修了。确实如此。太短了。我得告诉你，在剧中帮我做发型的金·费里（Kim Ferry），我们玩得超开心，因为我可以留有趣又时髦的发型。只要你知道，任何时候我都宁愿穿企鹅装也不要穿那个，因为企鹅装就像穿着一个睡袋。
There were so many different costumes at Dunder Mifflin. Jenna, it made me curious, what was the most popular Halloween costume last year? Oh, so I went and looked it up. I was a lady who Googled. We did a lot of Googling in the summer. We really did. Here was the top 10 according to Google Trends Fright Geist Halloween costumes of 2021. Number one, witch.
邓德米夫林有那么多不同的服装。珍娜，这让我很好奇，去年最受欢迎的万圣节服装是什么？哦，所以我去查了一下。我成了一个爱用谷歌搜索的人。我们在夏天做了大量的谷歌搜索。我们真的做了。根据谷歌趋势Fright Geist 2021年万圣节服装榜单，前十名如下。第一名，女巫。
Number two, rabbit. Number three, dinosaur. Number four, Spider-Man. Number five, Krula Deville. Number six, Ferry. Number seven, Harley Quinn. Number eight, Cowboy. Number nine, Clown.
第二名，兔子。第三名，恐龙。第四名，蜘蛛侠。第五名，库伊拉。第六名，仙女。第七名，哈莉·奎茵。第八名，牛仔。第九名，小丑。
Number 10, Chucky. Wow. Yeah. What was number two? Rabbit. Uh-huh. That one came out of left field for me. I know.
10号，恰吉。哇。是的。第二名是什么？兔子。嗯哼。这对我来说有点出乎意料。我知道。
More Halloween festivities are happening now. A few folks are playing with the Ouija board by front reception and Michael's determined to make a ghost called Daryl an ass. And then in the conference room, folks are bobbing for apples. We have a fan catch from Emily H in Tennessee that is so amazing. It's about this apple bobbing scene. Okay. Emily said, I thought my eyes were playing tricks on me, but I'm not making this up in
更多的万圣节庆祝活动正在进行。几个人在前台接待处玩着通灵板，迈克尔决心把一个叫达尔里的鬼魂整成一个笨蛋。然后在会议室里，大家在玩咬苹果游戏。我们收到了来自田纳西州Emily H的一位粉丝的投稿，实在是太棒了。是关于这个咬苹果的场景的。好的。Emily说，我还以为自己眼花缭乱了，但我绝对没有瞎编，
all caps. All throughout this episode, Meredith is wearing a blonde wig. But in the opening credits, starting with good by Michael, I believe, the scene in which Aaron is bobbing for apples is used and it shows Meredith in a red wig. Oh. I had to go back to this episode and sure enough, her wig is blonde. Why did they do that? I am sure many people have written in about this, but I just never noticed it until now.
全是大写字母。在这整集里，梅雷迪思都戴着一顶金发假发。但在片头字幕中，我记得从《再见，迈克尔》开始，使用的是艾伦在玩咬苹果的场景，里面显示梅雷迪思戴着一顶红发假发。哦。我不得不回头看这一集，果不其然，她的假发是金色的。他们为什么要这么做？我确信很多人都写信来问过这件事，但我直到现在才注意到。
So here's what I did. These extended credits of Aaron bobbing for apples, they've actually been playing since the beginning of this season. So the first thing I did was go back and look at the opening credits. And I even took a screenshot. The extended credits are in Andy's play and Meredith is wearing the blonde wig. Just like in this episode. And I thought, oh, well, maybe Emily is just mistaken.
所以我做了以下事情。艾伦玩咬苹果的这些加长片头，其实从这季初就开始播放了。所以我做的第一件事就是回去查看片头字幕。我甚至还截了图。加长版片头在《安迪的演出》里，梅雷迪思戴着金发假发。就像这一集里一样。我想，哦，好吧，也许只是Emily记错了。
So then I went forward to good by Michael. Same credit sequence. Her wig is red. What? Yeah. I took screenshots of both. Look, here's the shot from Andy's play. That's good by Michael.
所以我接着快进到了《再见，迈克尔》。同样的片头序列。她的假发是红色的。什么？是的。我把两者的画面都截了下来。看，这是《安迪的演出》里的镜头。那是《再见，迈克尔》。
Oh my gosh, that is bizarre. What is that about? Yeah, they clearly went in and recolored the wig for this credit sequence in good by Michael. But they'd been playing it with a blonde one the whole time, the rest of the season. There's got to be a reason. You know who we're going to ask. We're going to ask Randy. So when we get to it, we'll have an answer.
噢天哪，这太诡异了。这到底是怎么回事？是的，他们显然是在《再见，迈克尔》的片头序列中重新给假发换了颜色。但他们在这整季的其余时间里，一直都在播放金发版本的。一定是有什么原因。你知道我们要去问谁。我们要去问兰迪。所以等我们讲到那里时，就会有答案了。
Emily, thank you so much for pointing that out. I know. That was bonkers. Fantastic catch, Emily. In the kitchen, Todd Packer is sitting with a bunch of, well, they're like little brown lunch bags and they list all these different organs. And the last one is in his lap and it says trouser mouse. Danny says, I don't think that's going to go the way you hope it will.
Emily，非常感谢你指出这一点。我知道。那太离谱了。精彩的发现，Emily。在厨房里，托德·帕克尔坐在一堆……嗯，它们就像是棕色的小午餐袋，上面列出了各种不同的器官。最后一个在他膝盖上，上面写着“裤裆老鼠”。丹尼说，我觉得事情不会按你希望的那样发展。
Well Jim's going to come into the kitchen and he is going to confront Danny. He's going to say, Hey man, I'm just curious, how come you never called my wife back for that date? And Danny's like, Really? Oh, Packer's like, you're looking for someone to bang your wife? I love that line so much. It made me laugh out loud. Danny says, you know what?
吉姆要走进厨房去质问丹尼。他会说，嘿，兄弟，我只是好奇，你怎么从来没给我老婆回过电话去约会？丹尼说，真的吗？哦，帕克尔说，你在找人跟你老婆上床吗？我太喜欢这句台词了。逗得我哈哈大笑。丹尼说，你知道吗？
The truth is, I didn't call her back because all she talked about was you. She was clearly in love with you. Well that's not true. No, it's not. There is a deleted scene where you see Jim walk over to Pam, whisper something in her ear and she looks at him and shakes her head like, Nope. And then the next scene is them confronting him outside of the men's room. Yeah.
事实是，我没给她回电话，因为她嘴里念叨的全是你。她显然深爱着你。嗯，那不是真的。不，不是这样的。有一个被删减的片段，你可以看到吉姆走向帕姆，在她耳边低声说了句什么，然后她看着他，摇了摇头，像是在说“才不”。然后下一个场景就是他们在男洗手间外面质问他。是的。
And they demand to know the real reason why he never called her. Because if he doesn't tell her, it's just going to keep gnawing at her like, No, no, no, no, no. I thought you were so fantastic in the scene again. I looked at the shooting draft to see if there was any stage direction. This was just all you. The only thing they spelled out for you was the excuse me. Yes.
他们要求知道他从来不给她回电话的真正原因。因为如果他不告诉她，这件事就会一直折磨着她，就像……不，不，不，不，不。我觉得你在这一场里的表现又太棒了。我又看了一下拍摄剧本，看看有没有什么舞台指导。这全靠你们自己发挥。他们唯一给你明确写出来的只有那个“打扰一下”。是的。
It was all scripted. One part that I added was that, Yes, that was so great. All it says in the shooting draft is that you awkwardly exit. And how you chose to do that was all you. I showed the scene to Lee because I said to him, This might be one of the most me performances I've ever given. I am a little dorky and I feel like the writers were onto something about me, Jenna, because I do all of these things in my life.
全都是剧本里有的。我加进的一部分是，是的，那太棒了。拍摄剧本里唯一写的就是你尴尬地退场。至于你选择怎么做，全凭你自己的发挥。我把这一场给李看了，因为我对他说，这可能是我演过最“我”的表演之一了。我有点书呆子气，我觉得编剧们确实抓住了我的一些特质，珍娜，因为我在现实生活中也会做所有这些事情。
And you also remember stuff. So you would be the one like, Nope, nope. It was two. We had a third. You didn't call. That's how it went down. Yeah. They also really made all of this even more awkward by the fact that I am in a full, elaborate
而且你还很记事。所以你就会是那种人，比如：不，不。那是两个。我们有第三个。你没打电话。事情就是这样的。是的。他们真的把所有这一切搞得更加尴尬，因为我穿着一套完整、精致的
wigged costume. And I'm talking to these two handsome men just dressed in normal clothes. It really even further highlights Pam's dorkiness and your little, your little flat ponytail kept flopping around. I loved doing the scene and I really am so proud of it. We had a fan question from Ashley W in Suffolk, Virginia, who said, Why does Danny Cordray disappear after this episode? I loved the character and Timothy Oliphant isn't too shabby to look at either.
假发戏服。而我正跟这两个穿着普通衣服的帅哥说话。这真的更加突显了帕姆的书呆子气，而且你那个小小的、平平的马尾辫一直晃来晃去。我很喜欢拍这场戏，而且我真的为它感到非常自豪。我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州萨福克的Ashley W的一个粉丝提问，她说，为什么丹尼·科德雷在这一集之后就消失了？我很喜欢这个角色，而且蒂莫西·奥利芬特也挺帅的。
I'll tell you he is mentioned again in Michael's last dundies when Michael gives him the hottest in the office award. And there was a little bit where Michael tries to bring Danny up via satellite and it got cut out. It's in the deleted scenes. You know, the story is that Danny's on the road. It's how we see Todd Packer so infrequently. But this storyline did kind of get unresolved.
我告诉你，他在迈克尔的最后一次邓迪奖上又被提及了，当时迈克尔颁给了他办公室最性感奖。还有一个小片段，迈克尔试图通过卫星连线把丹尼请出来，但被剪掉了。它在删减片段里。你知道的，剧情解释说丹尼在出差。这就是为什么我们很少见到托德·帕克尔。但这条故事线确实有点不了了之了。
I agree, Ashley, because that scene was cut from Michael's last dundies. We assume that after Michael leaves, Danny is let go. He was a hire we didn't really need. We already had our traveling salesman. Right. But anyway, that you would have had at least a little nugget of information on him. Well, we're about to have a sit down with Gabe, Daryl and Michael to resolve all of this issue of who brings what information to what department, right?
我同意，阿什利，因为那个场景从迈克尔的最后一次邓迪奖中被剪掉了。我们推测在迈克尔离开后，丹尼就被解雇了。他是一个我们其实不需要的雇员。我们已经有我们的旅行推销员了。对吧。但无论如何，你本应该得到关于他的一点点信息。好吧，我们马上要和加布、达尔里和迈克尔坐下来开会，来解决这个到底谁向哪个部门汇报什么信息的问题，对吧？
Yeah. Gabe is going to tell Daryl that Daryl needs to get Michael's approval before coming to him with anything. And Daryl says, Well, you know what? You're going to miss out on some good ideas. And then Gabe goes, Well, then my door is always opened. And this leads to a back and forth where Michael's like after everything I've done for you. And Daryl looks at Michael and says, Listen, Ed Truck hired me, Joe promoted me, Gabe listened
是的。加布要告诉达尔里，达尔里在找他谈任何事情之前，需要先得到迈克尔的批准。达尔里说，好吧，你知道吗？你会错过一些好主意的。然后加布说，那我的大门永远为你敞开。这就导致了一来一回的争论，迈克尔说，在我为你做了这么多之后。而达尔里看着迈克尔说，听着，埃德·特克雇用我，乔晋升了我，加布听
to me. All you've ever done is say no to me. I have ambition. This is part of Daryl's storyline of where his ambition is going to take him. And he's really starting to feel it. Like he has good ideas and they're changing the way the company works. And he's going to have a scene with Andy where he initially says, sometimes I think things were better down in the warehouse, and then Andy goes on this very sort of elaborate metaphor
取我的意见。而你唯一做过的事就是对我说不。我有野心。这是达尔里故事线的一部分，关于他的野心将带他去向何方。他真的开始感受到这一点了。就像他有好主意，而且它们正在改变公司的运作方式。他将与安迪有一场对手戏，他在其中最初说，有时候我觉得在仓库里事情要好一些，然后安迪就开始发表这种非常精心设计的隐喻，
using acapella. Yes. And at the end of this scene, Daryl says he does have big plans and big ambitions. And we're going to see that storyline now play out through the rest of the series. Yeah. And Michael and Daryl make up. They both decide if they ever disagree with Gabe, they're going to go straight to Joe and they shake hands on it.
用的是无伴奏合唱。是的。在这场戏的结尾，达尔里说他确实有宏伟的计划和宏大的野心。我们将会看到这条故事线在接下来的剧集中展开。是的。而且迈克尔和达尔里言归于好了。他们都决定，如果他们与加布有任何分歧，他们会直接去找乔，并且他们为此握手言和。
And Michael says, you know what, friends fight. Well, I like that Daryl got to call Michael out in this episode. He deserved it. Jim is going to have a very sweet talking head. He's going to say, to be honest, I can't believe he didn't call her back. Who doesn't call a dork like that back? And now Jim is going to arrive dressed in the Popeye costume with CC as Sweet Pea. Her hero.
迈克尔说，你知道吗，朋友之间也会吵架。嗯，我喜欢达尔里在这集里敢于回怼迈克尔。他应得的。吉姆将有一段非常甜蜜的单人访谈。他说，说实话，我不敢相信他没给她回电话。谁会不给这样一个书呆子回电话呢？现在吉姆将穿着大力水手服装闪亮登场，CC则打扮成甜豌豆。她的英雄。
How cute did they look all dressed up? I mean, I'm sorry. It was so freaking adorable. Did every woman's heart leap out of her chest when he walked in the door as Popeye carrying Sweet Pea or what? So cute. So cute. The day we filmed that, I took a picture of John in the Popeye costume and holding
他们盛装打扮看起来多可爱啊！我是说，对不起。简直太萌了。当他穿着大力水手服装走进来，手里抱着甜豌豆时，是不是所有女性的心都漏跳了一拍？太可爱了。太可爱了。我们拍摄的那天，我拍了一张约翰穿着大力水手服装、怀里抱着
the sweet little baby. I still have the picture. So cute. Well, John is very much like Steve. They both just love kids so much. And John and I would just dote on those little babies all the time. I know. I loved having those girls on set.
那个可爱小宝宝的照片。我到现在还留着那张照片。太可爱了。嗯，约翰真的很像史蒂夫。他们两个都超级喜欢小孩子。我和约翰总是会百般疼爱那些小宝宝。我知道。我好喜欢让那些小女孩来到片场。
We are now going to reveal who won the coupon book. We get to see some people flash up their cards, kind of like Survivor Style, who they wrote down. Kelly voted for Oscar, Ryan voted for Oscar, Creed voted for Oscar. Oscar won. Yeah. There was a scene that would have come after this. It's in deleted scenes.
我们现在要揭晓谁赢得了优惠券书。我们可以看到一些人亮出他们的卡片，有点像《幸存者》风格，写下了他们投票给谁。凯利投给奥斯卡，瑞安投给奥斯卡，克里德投给奥斯卡。奥斯卡赢了。是的。本来在这之后还有一个场景。在删减片段里。
Creed Meredith, Ryan, Kelly, and Angela have gathered around Oscar as he reads from the coupon book. Oh, I love this. I feel like they gave Oscar a lot of alts for this. Here are a few that were in the script as well as deleted scenes. Oscar says, who wants $30 off any full fare ticket on a flight to Chicago? Blackout date supply. Who wants a free power boost at Body Shakes Boba Bar?
克里德、梅雷迪思、瑞安、凯利和安吉拉围聚在奥斯卡周围，听他朗读优惠券书。哦，我喜欢这个。我觉得他们为奥斯卡在这个桥段设计了很多备选台词。以下是剧本以及删减片段中的几条。奥斯卡说，谁想要一张飞往芝加哥的航班、任何正价票立减30美元的优惠券？黑纸白字限制条件适用。谁想要在奶茶果冻吧免费获得一次能量提升？
Who wants a 100 megabyte MP3 player special bonus does not play iTunes? Who wants a free estimate on carpet cleaning? Oh, look, 5% off your Dunder Mifflin order. Ask for Stand the Man. And then the camera reveals a smiling photo of Stanley from 20 years ago. I have a question. How are people reacting in the scene? Are they getting it?
谁想要一个100兆字节的MP3播放器，特别附赠不支持iTunes功能？谁想要一份免费的地毯清洁估价？哦，看，你的邓德·米夫林订单享受5%的折扣。找“男人的斯坦”。然后镜头揭晓了一张斯坦利20年前面带微笑的照片。我有一个问题。大家在这个场景里的反应是怎样的？他们get到了吗？
Are they like finally getting that maybe the coupon book wasn't great or are they still wishing they had the coupon book? No, with each one, they're like, ah, pass, ah. And then Kelly's like, Oscar, get to the good stuff. And then that's when he gets to Stand the Man. That's great. Oh, well guys, that was costume contest. Yes, we hope you have a great week.
他们是不是终于意识到也许这本优惠券书并不怎么样，还是说他们仍然希望自己能拥有这本优惠券书？不，随着每一张的宣读，他们都在说，啊，跳过，啊。然后凯利说，奥斯卡，说点有用的！然后就在那时，他读到了“男人的斯坦”。太棒了。哦，好吧，伙计们，那是服装大赛。是的，我们希望你们有一个美好的一周。
Thanks for listening. Thank you, Randy Cordray. And thanks to Phil Rosenthal for coming in and eating some, in my opinion, disgusting chips. And thank you to all of you. Yes. Thank you for sending in all your wonderful messages and gifts. We love you.
感谢收听。谢谢兰迪·科德雷。也要谢谢菲尔·罗森塔尔来吃一些在我看来非常恶心的薯片。还要谢谢你们所有人。是的。谢谢你们发来的所有精彩留言和礼物。我们爱你们。
We love you so much. See you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe.
我们太爱你们了。下周见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利共同制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 注册即可享受一个月的免费试用，使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。